thế Alo ạ Alo các bạn nghe th được không
ạ chào các
xa
Ờ các bạn nghe thế không ạ Alo
alo alo
không không vào phải xem setting như thế
nào
do cái này
a nói gì
thoại người biết được h Mở chính kênh
YouTube mình lấ được mà
nhh YouTube À đây có tiếng có tiếng ok
rồi Các bạn thấy bị bé quá thì C bảo
mình
nhá Thì hôm nay sẽ là một buổi kiểu
livestream đây mình sẽ định ghim lại cái
câu Thực ra ngoài việc tâm sự trả lời
một vài câu hỏi của các bạn ra thực ra
là hôm nay gần như là
mình sẽ là người hỏi các bạn nữa
kiểu nói chung là tôi sẽ kiểu gọi là hỏi
nhờ các bạn hỗ trợ giải đáp Vân Vân đó
là nói chung là tôi định hôm nay sẽ có
những cái thứ cần nói này là đầu tiên
là chia sẻ cái gì chia sẻ này đúng không
Tâm sự
một là tâm sự chia sẻ
nhỉ Những cái đã ghi này tiếp theo
hướng tương tương lai của
mình đấy Cái này nó nó sẽ bao gồm rất
nhiều bao gồm việc là có thể là từ chính
kênh này đi Kênh này hay là nghê nghiệp
này hay thậm chí
là thậm chí những cái xa hơn mọi người
có thể hỏi ví dụ là chuyện gia đình
chẳng hạn định thế Ờ à còn quên trả lời
câu hỏi nữa nhá Tôi ghi kiểu này cho đợ
phải đánh dấu số thứ tự
trả lời các câu hỏi thực tế hôm trước
tôi mới để ý là kiểu tôi để cái form của
tôi là mỗi người chỉ được hỏi một câu
thôi nên là có có khi không biết có bạn
nào dính không là bạn nào đó vào thấy
kểu ơ câu hỏi của mình chỉ trả lời một
câu một câu xong thôi Chắc là sẽ
tôi đ để cho mỗi người chỉ hỏi một câu
là để tránh bị
spam nên là tôi nhn định làm thế mà tôi
đang cân nhắc Ờ ở đây Ừ đúng rồi Ở đây
Có timestamp
à đợi t tí tôi kéo sang bên này
đã tôi sẽ mở thest lên rồi tôi sẽ sắp
xếp
theo thời gian
cần nhất thì lên đầu đấy
đúng
à câu cập nhật được gần nhất đên đầu
nghe cũng hợp lý mà đúng không
ơ lộ mất rồi lộ mất
rồi lội mất email rồi à đ
rồi không không nên để lội th tin các
bạn
quên trước đấy thì tôi sẽ phải hỏi các
bạn về cái việc
là dự nó th nó cũng dự định tương lai
thôi bở ngay trong tháng sau
là tháng sau đây nhì rõ cuối tháng sau
ngặc tháng
tám mình sẽ vào đ
Nẵng kiểu đi du lịch với công ty ấ nó sẽ
tranh thủ là bỏ lại một vài ngày để mà
gặp kiểu gặp các bạn nếu mà ai có tiện
có thể gặp được thì mình xin vé hẹn để
anh em mình có thể gặp nhau biết
đâu ai cũng có câu chuyện mình mà tôi
muốn lắng nghe các bạn xong rồi giao lưu
các thứ như thế nào đấy và sẽ vào Đà
Nẵng
này thì tôi vào đây định là sẽ là
ờ ngoài việc là đi giao lưu tâm sự đúng
không g lưu chọn cà phê trò chuyện ch
lại tôi còn định là vé thăn à thăn không
đúng
bên ft một tí ở trong Đà Nẵng kiểu để mà
xem ssop trong đề xị sò như nào thì
không biết là trong đ có FPT academy
không nhưng mà nói chung là hồi trước
cái viễn cảnh Hồi trước của tôi đó
là là kiểu phề dạy ở trong Đà Nẵng thì
rõ ràng là ở Hà Nội về sau nó k s bồ ấy
kiểu đ đúc rồi thì mình nghĩ là nếu mà
lúc mà mình cái Hill mình hạn ch sồ thì
tôi Tôi vẫn nhớ cái ấn tượng Chắc là
phải từ hội cấp hai đến giờ à hồi lớp 9
hồi lớp 9 là mình tầm hồi lớp 9 là mình
tầm bao tuổi nhỉ 15
tuổi
à 15 tuổi mình à vào Đà Nẵng một lần thì
là đấy trải nghiệm mọi thứ rất là tốt th
kiểu cả con người thân thiện các thứ thc
ra tôi cũng có vài người bán ở trong đấy
nữa n tôi cũng biết được vài người bạn
đấy đã từng ra Hà Nội và cảm thấy là bị
sóc về văn hóa đấy thì tôi muốn là Hồi
đấy tôi định là kiểu sẽ vào Đà Nẵng để
mà kiểu ăn cơm Lạt nghiệp cũng đúng đại
khái lúc Mà kiểu cũng kiểu cứ cho là cận
kề tuổi về hưu đi Chưa hẳn về hưu hẳn
mình sẽ và vấy nói chung khi mà mình
nghe cái S bồ rồi thì mình
sẽ về đấy Ở dậy và nghe nói Hồi đấy tôi
vẫn nhớ hồi đấy là ft con hỗ trợ mua nhà
ở chung cư của họ Hình như họ tự xây cái
chung cư rồi hỗ trợ cái gì gì đó như cái
đấy tôi đặp t rất là lâu rồi Nói chung
là mọi thứ bây giờ còn thay đổi nữa cái
hồi mà anh em J2 team community Vote là
cái bình chọn thành phố đáng s số nhất
thấy có Đà Nẵng Đấy thấy có mùi rồi là
ai cũng muốn về đấy chắc là về sau nó
lại show
mất nó có thể không phải là một cái Hà
Nội thứ hai như tô tin là nó có thể
thành một cái Sài Gòn Thứ hai là kiểu
dân từ sứ đổ về ấ hiểu không đấy Nên là
cũng hơi sợ nhưng mà tôi vẫn muốn vào
đấy Để xem mọi thứ như nào đồng thời là
xem thử FPT trong đấy nào hố trước tôi
đã có dự định rất lâu tôi đã từng hứa
hẹn với anh em rồi đó là
sẽ offline ở trong đấy và cái hồi mà
định tổ chức à tổ chức
offline cho J2 team Unity ấ ở trong Sài
Gòn tôi ý định là kiểu gì cũng sẽ làm
cái tương tự giống ở Đà Nẵng là nhờ f hỗ
trợ các th thứ nhưng mà đương nhiên là
bây giờ tôi không có là kiểm duyệt của
nhóm nên là tự đừng ra làm mọi bây giờ
Không không có khả thi nữa chưa biết là
sau này sẽ thế nào nhưng mà tôi vẫn vẫn
muốn ngó qua trước đã muốn ngó qua Mọi
thứ trước đúng không Nói chung là trong
thủ dịch thì à ghé FPT này
Đấy ghé nhờ dùng từ nhờ thì Ờ tôi đang
tôi đang a rồi mấy ông sẽ biết được nếu
mà ông gặp tôi ngoài đời sẽ biết là tôi
thường hay kể mình gọi là như nào nhỉ th
nhất là mình chả lá ai cả mình chả B xị
cả mình chẳng xi rõ rà gì hơn người mình
chẳng phải nổi tiếng hay mình xuất thân
gì đó Vân Vân không tài chính cũng càng
không chắc chắn là không có tài chính
thi nên là thành ra là tất cả phải đi cơ
cấu vào nhờ và quan hệ kiểu là ờ nhờ
được cái gì thì nhờ đươ nhiên là nó sẽ
có đánh đổi thôi Cái gì có qua có lại
đúng không À mình thôi
thì thì mình định là mình sẽ phải nhờ cơ
cấu để mà được vào vào ft để ngó đ nhờ
người th Tôi đang nhờ người quen không
được thì chắc là tôi sẽ phải nhờ anh em
xem ông nào có cái thẻ để cho tôi vào
ngó không biết là được không cơ
đấy rồi nhờ tiếp
chị thì thì không biết Chắc là bây giờ
mấy ông mới biết là quên Nội Tôi ở trong
Quảng
Trị là trên giấy tờ tôi thế V các đời
ông bà thì cũng đều ra đây rồi ra Hà Nội
rồi nên thành ra kiểu thôi sẽ vào đấy để
mà
kiểu nói chung là về th quê nội gốc gác
thôi và tôi chắc là ở đây cũng sẽ phải
hỏi anh em về nếu có ai rồi tôi nghĩa là
học sinh của tôi kiểu gì có có thể có
thể có người ở đây ấ Chắc là có thì sẽ
hỏi anh em xem là mọi thứ trong đấy như
nào Ví dụ Thời tiết chẳng hạn bác Tô hôm
trước b vào thời tiết nắng vãy chư vào
đấy x nắng các thờ thứ nghe cũng sợ
chứ tiếng có bị dè hai tiếng bất ổn gì
không ạ thì tôi trỉ lại nhá Chào các bạn
Bạn cứ chat nhá Tôi vẫn tôi vẫn đọc thôi
Anh nghĩ sao về si sá ở Việt Nam ạ Các
bạn thường ha hỏi mấy câu này chắc là
các bạn đang phân vân rất nhiều cái theo
tôi thì
ơ si sáp à si sá Tôi nhớ là có người
quen tôi làm x sát th chuyển vọng mà nó
không phải làm cái kiểu dạng làm cái Quá
khó để mà Học để theo còn còn nếu mà Giả
sử bạn theo mà bạn thấy là cái về sau ấy
về sau Kiểu cái định hướng à Không Cơ
Hội nghề nghiệp không còn mấy nữa thì
bạn đ nhảy sang ngôn ngữ khác không vấn
để gì cả Không sao học đọc trình cho thế
bây giờ ngôn ngyễn nào cũng chẳng quan
trọng
lắm làm tình năng thanh toán online đ
cái cái này chắc là em chưa biết cách
kiểu tra đúng bởi vì em thấy là cái đấy
có vô số có nhiều ý và gọi nhở
ngoài thư viện mọi thứ có nhiều nhá Nó
còn cung cấp tận răng giống như ở Việt Q
Việ Hình như
TH có mấy cái đấy api có hết mà Đấy Tôi
sẽ định là như này định nó
qua đ tôi sẽ phải nhờ anh em ch x v mấy
cái này Ok nhỉ
t em Java Tôi chỉ nhớ là chỉ có mỗi pp
thằng anay nói là ngôn ngữ đã chết thôi
chứ Java TH Nghĩa là được đối với tôi
khái
niệm theo theo theo tôi theo tôi gọi là
sắp xếp nhá theo cái bảng xếp hạn của
tôi nhá thì tôi cảm thấy là JavaScript
đứng đầu là chắc chắn rồi thì thấy là cả
làm cả funen backend các thứ tiếp theo
là à
Java là kiểu đông người tuyển nhất
ấy
đấy còn sau đó thì với tôi thì sẽ là pp
pp tôi sẽ đứng bằng với đọt nét này này
sĩ sá này C thử thử Đấy đấy là theo tôi
và xếp hạ của tôi đương nhiên là với
người với người khác có thể là Python
này các thứ à re thì T nhiên là nó đ ra
scrip rồi vẫn cục chung rồi
đúng
trước hay là chả câu hỏi trước
xong rồi Các ông có thắc mắc hỏi gì À
đấy Linh nhỉ Linh Câ hỏi thì cũng là
link Mọi khi đúng
ừ Hồi trước tôi để một cái link
này vẫn đợi cái ngày Facebook tôi trở về
tôi có thể đăng được mấy link này lên
Ờ tôi Tôi không nhớ đúng link này là là
cái gì
nữa xin phép tắt cái này vào đâu đó
đó không muốn nỡ xóa à Nhờ tôi chia sẻ
trong discord server discord rồi nhỉ
Thôi t để chắc thì tôi sẽ tạo đều nó ra
đây
đã tính Tôi là người thích chia sẻ không
cả nhớ bạn quen tôi bạn sẽ thấy tôi spam
bạn rất nhiều cái luôn đầu tiên thì cái
này tôi tôi nhớ là mấy cái link tôi để
spotify đều là liên quan đến Spider rum
Spider room gọi Spider room book đúng
không
Đây một câu hỏi đúng quan trọng hơn bạn
câu trả lời đấy Đây là một câu hay này
ờ tôi để lại cho bạn mấy bạn cái link
này sau
nhá À đúng rồi link ở đây là để tôi tâm
sự luôn đấy quên Đạ à Thì cái này tôi đã
từng nói các bạn rồi đó là
kiểu muốn muốn câu trả lời có tâm thì
mình sẽ phải đặt một câu hỏi có tâm thế
nào là câu hỏi có tâm thường là nó là
một câu hỏi mình mình tốn chất xám vào
nó thôi nghĩa là chỉ là là mình cũng
phải tìm hiểu trước trước khi đưa câu
hỏi này mình thể Thử làm thử thử nhớ cái
trước và và đôi khi ở hồi trước còn có
cái khái niệm nó như này nhở tô đã từng
thấy là có một vài người hỏi xong rồi
mình đưa câu trả lời không nói tôi nhá
Tôi đã từng thấy thôi Đó là kiểu xong
rồi người ta phản bác lại cái câu trả
lời đấy kể tao làm thử rồi nhưng không
được đấy là một câu rất đến hình chẳng
ạn hoặc là kiểu mày nói thế là sai rồi
Vân Vân mà rõ ràng là người kia cũng cố
trả lời lại theo cái kiến thức của họ
rồi có thể nó sẽ không đúng theo mà mình
muốn nhưng mà nó vẫn là sự đón nhận gì
gì đó còn nếu mà câu hỏi bạn muốn hỏi
bạn gọi như này hồi trước có câu đó là
bạn không nên hỏi những cái mà bạn không
muốn nghe câu trả lời ấ đấy Kiểu
để ngồi thẳng lưng Tôi nghĩ cái bàn này
tôi cái bàn này Thực ra cũng tự đặt đấy
đặt đấy chứ nó không không gọi
nhỉ Tôi cảm thấy nó không tiện đâu Ừ cái
lần cuối Tôi nhớ là lần cuối tôi lần
cuối livestream là ha tháng trước cũng
quay video vở này và cũng đá vơ Tôi vẫn
nhớ
à các bạn sẽ lại bảo Tôi có cái áo Mặc
đi mặc lại nhưng mà
thôi Mình là vơ
mà đáy sẵn rồi ngại gì Ờ đấy thì nói
chung là về tôi khái niệm là một câu hỏi
đúng rất rất quan trọng bởi vì đôi khi
các bạn trong lúc các bạn đặt câu hỏi
các bạn tự vận động não suy nghĩ x các
thứ thứ đôi khi là mình cũng vẫn lẽ ra
khá nhiều rồi cái việc là hỏi lại chỉ
mang tính chất là chắc chắn lại cái đáp
án của mình vân vân để tham khảo cũng
như là kểu để thêm được góp nhìn khác
thôi góc nhìn từ người ngoài thôi thôi
Khi mà tôi đặt câu hỏi thường là tôi
kiểu mang thên hướng là như thế hơn ví
dụ ví dụ ở trên công ty tôi bây giờ ch
Tôi từng nói các bạn rồi tôi h ham học
hỏi lắm tôi hỏi liên tục mà hỏi anh đ
tôi liên tục nhưng mà tôi không bao giờ
kiểu dạng là hỏi kiểu là chẳng biết gì
xong quay ra hỏi
thì thì tôi thường m phải nghiên cứu
trước nghiên cứu kì đã để biết được
là cái cái mình đang mình đang nói nó sẽ
là cái gì đúng không đấy chứ không phải
là đợi một người cho ăn sẵn một
người kiểu trả lời hết cho mình mình chả
phải nghĩ gì cả Thế thì không đúng rồi
một cách hỏi là cách để mình nói ra vấn
đề hay là cách để mà mình tự nói với bản
thân mình tự hỏi chất vấn B thân mình
đấy Nên là câu hỏi rất quan trọng đúng
sẽ không dối như mình mình gặp vấn đề
đấy mình người trực tiếp bị tác động bởi
nó mình sẽ bị
rối tiếp
nhỉ fomo cái này tôi vẫ sẽ để link nhá
để link ạ
gì không
ạ Nếu các bạn tra rồi Hoặc là chư tra
Tôi sẽ trả lời tôi phải tra lại đi tra
lại t mấy
lần cái này tôi tôi chuẩn bị phát âm
phát â tiếng Anh có thể là nó sẽ
không không đúng ch lắm Đúng rồi fear of
Missing out
th không đúng tiếng anh kệ nhá Ờ thì
dịch ra đại khái nó sẽ là
kể đôi khi là mình nĩ Cái đấy là nỗi sợ
chung bây giờ đặc biệt là thời đại công
nghệ Bây giờ thời đại kiể phát triển
nhanh vân vân
đấy nhiều người gi bị phô Tứ cả nhiều
người đang sợ là mình bỏ lỡ cái điều gì
đó Có thể là lỡ một cái tin tức nóm hổi
mấy cái biến đôi khi là mấy cái công
nghệ gì đó mình bị trậm chân đấy
Nhưng
mà theo tôi quan điểm nó
k Thực ra là bây giờ mình đang bị quá
nhiều nỗi sợ mình đôi khi mình
có chính mình tạo ác lực khiến m thân
mình sợ rất nhiều thứ và và với tôi Ấy
đươ nhên là cuộc sống phải có sợ nhá tấn
cuộc sống bắt buộc phải có sợ Theo tôi
nghĩ thế một người không biết sợ một cái
gì cả thì khi không làm được gì không Ví
gì Ví dụ tiền hình bạn sợ nghèo bạn sợ
đói bạn sợ không chăm sóc được cho gia
đình mình không lo được cho gia đình
mình thì mình mình còn có động lực mà
phấn đấu để mà tránh cái điều đấy Nó xảy
ra đúng không theo tôi sợ từ sợ nó dẫn
đến hành động là như thế nhưng mà sợ đám
trẻ thôi Mình không làm gì cả thì cái sợ
đấy nó thành vô dụng mất
rồi thì cái Sợ của Bị bọ lỡ rất nhiều
cái này thì theo tôi
là thay vì mình suy nghĩ là mình sợ mình
hãy suy nghĩ nếu mà theo theo góc độ góc
độ nào tâm linh à hay là góc độ gì gì đó
nó là tốc độ kiểu nhìn the cả tôi nhớ là
câu triết lý của ấn ày gì gì lại khá cái
gì đến thì nó sẽ đến hay
gì người nào
như thế tức
là mình đừng có sợ là mình hãy luôn phải
chuẩn bị tâm lý cho những cái tình huống
đấy ví dụ là
học được có quá nhiều kiến thức vân vân
mình lại ngượng non hào đá mình kiểu
mình kiểu cảm thấy là kiến thức của mình
chư đủ để đi làm vân vân mình cứ cố học
cố học họ càng nhiều cng và mình nghĩ là
càng nhiều càng tốt X phải còn ra bao
nhiêu kiến thức mới bao nhiêu cuốn sách
mới Mình lại cứ cắm đầu và học các th
thứ dẫn đến cái quá tải đấy kể thế thay
mình như thế thì mình vẫn phải để não
mình nghỉ ngơi
chứ Đấy theo theo tôi thì
mình mình có sợ mình vẫn phải có chuẩn
bị và mình phải bước đến đâu chắc đến
đấy mình đừng có chạy theo phong trào
mình có chạy theo đám đông đám đông có
thể đây mình cái pho này nó thể hiện vi
là là xu thế mà đúng không Mình cứ phải
cố chạy theo xu thế không đừ mình chạy
như thế Nói thẳng luôn xu thế nó sẽ luôn
rất là thay đổi rất là nhanh mình không
thể bắt kịp được nó đâu mình nên
tự mình đi mình không cần phải chạy đua
với ai cả mình chạy đua với chính mình
thôi nĩa là ví dụ là bạn so với một năm
trước bạn đã thay đổi được những cái gì
bạn đã cải thiện thêm những gì đấy sẽ
tốt hơn là bạn so sánh bạn bạn những bạn
bè đồng lứa đồng nghiệp hay thậ chí là
mấy cái ông nào đó nói linh tinh trên
mạng như tôi chẳng hạn mà dành như thế
nó chẳng có tác dụng gì cả
đấy rõ ràng là người lại nó sẽ chỉ tạo
thêm áp lực và nó sẽ cáng khiến cho bạn
cái áp lực đấy Nó kiểu không phải áp lực
tốt đấy theo tôi là như thế đấy Tôi luôn
So sánh tôi với quá khứ thôi tôi không
so sánh tôi với người khác đấy người
khác thì có thể có thể chắc chắn là sẽ
có lúc So sánh tôi với họ hay với ai đó
thôi tôi thì kệ
thôi bản thân bản thân mình hồi bé chắc
là kiểu gì mình sẽ bị so sánh với con
nhà người ta rồi thứ Vân vận th còn chả
biết con này người ta thấy thồn tại hay
không đúng không ạ nhưng
mà mình đừng có để lớn lên mình cũng bị
cái áp lực tâm lý đấy nữa Tôi nghĩ là
bây giờ mình bị chung và cái t bị bệnh
tâm lý rất nhiều cái nế là theo tôi là
né được cái nào né đúng không Ok Đấy một
cái về này thì đấy nếu mà Tóm tắt lại
cái tôi vừa nói nó sẽ chỉ là cái gì đến
nó sẽ đến Mí
tôi lỡ chỉnh cái này nó lỗi tôi khi mà
tôi lỡ chỉnh nó hơi xa được chưa ạ Đỡ
chưa
ạ Alo ạ Alo
alo Bây giờ tôi không tiện để mà đứng
dậy để mà chỉnh lại cái mic này trong
cảm ch đề không khác thực ra là h khác
hơi khó th khá tôi mới thay đổi
cái thay đổi lại cái góc này vì tôi
không b thì hôm nay tôi định nói là chưa
chắc là tôi sẽ quay lại livestream
thường xuyên Ờ bởi vì là đấy hôm trước
có người hỏi thì tôi bảo
là tôi đang phải học hỏi rất nhiều cái
hoàn thiện bản thân nhiều cái đấy nó trả
lời cái câu cho cái câu
mà Yêu Lại Từ Đầu về các bài giảc cũ
thành mới cho sinh viên đang học lĩnh
vực it công nghệ công ty đi ạ đấy thì
gọi là như nào có thể là ở đây có một
vài bạn thì là năm mới năm nhất năm hai
thì có thể là nghe tôi thì thấy là k Ừ y
ra anh này đi làm rồi thì anh ấy có gì
đó thì anh ấy nói được mà nếu mà tôi tự
đánh giá tôi thì tôi lại cả lại thấy là
bản thân mình tôi luôn tôi luôn thấy
chính xác là thế đấy Tôi bị tự tạo áp
lực bản thân mình nhiều chứ tôi luôn
thấy
mình giống như là đang
lừa không biết là các bạn có giờ tô nghĩ
bản thân mình thế không như rất nhiều l
tự tự trách bản thân mình hay là mình có
đang lừa người khác không Tại sao là
dùng tể lừa Nếu mà nói thẳng ra là nó
thế Tại sao dùng tề lừa đây vì tôi cảm
thấy là kiểu ví ví dụ nhá nhá tôi lại
quay lại câu chuyện lúc mà tôi mới ra
trường thì tôi được ở lại để mà giảng
dạy ở trường đương nhiên là kiến thức
của tôi
đủ đủ
để không biết bị dính tạ âm không chắc
là có đợ thì đợi một tí
được ở lại được nhận ở lại để làng dậy
vởi vì thiếu Gióng viên chứ tôi tự đánh
giá tôi là kẹo đấy chưa qua trên lớp về
đào tạo Sư phạm gì cả chỉ mới được đúng
chợ dng 2 3 tháng và được ở lại dậy vậy
Tư nhiên là toàn bộ kiến thức cơ bản đấy
tôi Đư nhiên vẫn phải phấn đấu để mà dạy
được tốt dạy đúng chứ Nhưng nói chung là
kiểu Hồi đấy đi dậy khẳng định luôn là
chắc chắn là kiến thức gọi là trải
nghiệm thực tế còn rất nhiều thiếu sót
vì rõ ràng là mình mới đi thực tập ở một
công ty thôi Sau đó thì mình ở lại đi
dạy luôn đ nh là dạy vẫn là ki những
kiến thức cơ bản mà lý thuyết thì mình
nắm nhưng tôi cảm thấy là mình không thể
gọi là không thể đủ kiến thức để mà
truyền tải hết được cho sinh viên đấy
đặc biệt là năm nhất năm đầu tiên tôi đi
dậy nữa tôi nói thẳng luôn là kiểu có
quá nhiều sai sót đươ nhiên là nói thẳng
luôn đến bây giờ tôi vn vẫn đấy tôi bảo
tôi vẫn Đôi khi tôi cảm thấy giống như
mình đang lừa mà
vì các bạn có nghe tôi nói rồi đấy nĩ
Tôi cảm thấy Tôi đang cố càng càng phấn
đấu để bản thân mình tốt hơn so quá khứ
nên khi mà tôi ở thời điểm hiện tại tôi
nhìn về quá khứ của tôi Tôi cảm thấy ô
Hồi đấy mình kiến thức vẫn còn nhiều thứ
sót quá vẫn còn kiểu trẻ con bồng bột
hay đủ thứ quá đấy Thế mà mình dám đi
dậy thế mà mình được phép kiểu đứng lớp
hay vân vân thậm chí là dạy online luôn
đấy Bây giờ tôi mà Thế nên là bạn kia
nói việc là
dạy lại hay thậm chí là tôi còn có lúc
cân nhắc việc là xóa những cái video cũ
của tôi dạy đi bởi vì tôi cảm thấy là
đáng lẽ là mình có thể dạy tốt hơn được
nữa nó nó vẫn chưa nằm ở Kiến thức sai
đâu nhưng mà nó sẽ là kến thức có thể
chưa đủ là một hoặc là mình có thể dạy
được một cách hay hơn đấy Nói chung là
tôi thường hay nghĩ cái điều
đấy Nó là kiểu cái tâm lý TH tự tạo ra
thôi không ít ra đế V hiện tại tôi cảm
thấy là vẫn lạc quan là chưa có học sinh
sinh viên nào đó kiểu V trách tôi về vân
vân cách dạy Hy mọi thứ họ có thể trách
tôi về cái khác
trách nhưng mà chưa Giờ trách về cách
dạy vì tôi cảm thấy là tôi khii dạy tôi
đã tương đối cống hiến đủ cái tâm huyết
mình rồi nghĩa là mình mình dạy vì cái
tâm mà nên mình sẽ cố hết sức thì người
ta không chê được cái tâm mình nhưng mà
về khoản kiến thức mọi thứ ấ Tôi nghĩ là
chắc chắn là mình vẫn còn rất nhiều thứ
sót nên là thế nên tôi mới Thường An nói
đó là tôi phải học thêm rất nhiều cái
nữa thì tôi mới dám tự tin kiểu sang FPT
dậy này chẳng hạn đấy đấy là cái qu điểm
Tôi nghĩ
biết cái mic của tôi nó bị dính vào một
cái tạp âm này không
mế không đợi tí là tôi đóng cửa sổ Phát
ạ Ngoài kia như bắt đầu tự nhiên Mở
chương trình cam nhà khác h
việc lần sau sẽ chuẩn bị tốt hơn trước
khi chim này ạ test lại mọi thứ đã
nền nhạc nhá ĩ ra nhạc này vẫn Chắc là
vẫn nghe được đúng không Tiếng quạt
à có có
quạt quạt ở góc này mà nh
cái
tiếng Đèn hút muỗi đèn hô muỗi cắm cả
ngày cháng hiểu sá cái đèn này nó bị
thôi còn một cái đèn nữa thì không bị
tiếng hơi lạ như tôi cảm thấy cái đèn
như tôi từng gọi là quảng cáo cái đèn
này tôi vẫn thấy là hiệu quả phải trưởng
vì
mở nó hiệu quả ấ gọi là 400.000 xứng
đáng gì
cũng hay mà cũng hay mà tôi nhiều lúc
tôi nghĩ tôi sẽ mở nhạc để ngồi tâm sự
rồi cái nhạc này vào chắc là không biết
mấy ông nghe thấy nhạc không nh tại khái
là nhạc này vào không biết có bị tính
bẩn quyền không nhỉ Hi vọng
mình thu âm lại được xong rồi ăn
gận
cái đó là hình như tôi từng nói các bạn
đề vậ cái này rồi theo tôi
thì tôi đã từng rủ một vài người
và không vài vài nó hơi bị ít chắc là
phải đến trăm rồi bao gồm cả Vic đi cà
phê hoặc là đi chơi bot game Vân Vân đi
làm nhiều cái cả trai cả gái nhá Không
mấy ông lại bảo tôi chỉ
chỉ chỉ kiểu đi gọi sim à đấy Kiểu V
Thế thì đại khái thì rất nhiều Bạn nhều
Ngoài việc những các bạn kiểu
hướng cứ chọn là hướng ngoại đi Bạn đừng
nhan thì có rất nhiều người bạn sẽ là tự
nhận mình người hướng nội ngại gặp người
lạ vân vân đấy thầ thấy từ chối là với
lý do là em ngại gặp người
lạ thì tôi lại thường hay nói các bạn để
cái quan điểm này cứ cho đây đây đây là
chuyên mục nhảy sang chuyên mục tâm lý
học tí thao túng tâm lý tí
thì nó là theo tôi theo góp nhìn nhận
của tôi nhé Nó
là có rất nhiều người đa số là bây giờ
đang thế đó là thích cái gì khái nệm tự
nhiên đấy đấy theo g nhìn tôi cảm thấy
là người ta thích cái gì đó tự nhiên ví
dụ là một một quan hệ tình yêu đến tự
nhiên thay vì em kiểu ngồi l tinder hay
là dùng cái app Thì đó hoa chiến là chủ
động ra ngooài tì người người kia thì em
muốn tự nhiên nó đến không biết tự nhiên
ở đâu ra Nhưng mà đại khái Bạn thích cái
gì tự nhiên vô tình gặp đấy thì
thế đấy là một cái trường
hợp trường hợp kiểu kiểu thế thôi tương
tự là tự nhiên nữa ví dụ là đấy bao gồm
việc là em có ít bạn bè em muốn nó cái
tự nhiên thay vì kiểu bây giờ mình chủ
động đi cà phê chủ động đi gặp đi chơ
đi chơi b là một cách để
đúng
không Nhà tôi không ở đấy từ nhà tôi tôi
ở khu tập thể cũ ở tầng hai có vẻ tầng 1
dưới kia đang kểu gì đó
hơi lạ nói chung là tự nhiên hôm nay mở
nhạc
à Thy đ Đang nói rồi Thì đại khái thì
nhiều bạn thích cái yếu tố tự nhiên kiểu
muốn có bạn bè một cách tự nhiên tôi cảm
thấy nó hơi bị lạ vì rõ ràng
là rất nhiều cái mình nên chủ động thì
nó sẽ tốt hơn ví dụ
nhá chủ động trong việc hẹn hò tìm hiểu
chẳng hạn đấy thay vì bạn bị động là đợi
người kia đợi người
kia đợi người kia chủ động ấy Mình hãy
chủ động lên việc việc là mình tự đi đến
hay V đợi người kia đón cũng là một cái
Điền hình đấy đ các bạn nữ nhá các bạn
nam mà để bạn nữ đón thì có hiệ tuyệt
vời quá nhưng mà tôi đang nói trong
trường hợp kiểu kiểu thế nghĩa là nếu
các bạn chủ động được một vài
cái các bạn chủ động đến ấy thì các bạn
sẽ chủ động về được vì Nếu giả sử các
bạn thấy không thoải mái không hài lòng
V việc đấy các bạn có thể bỏ vấy đỗi hay
vì kể đây tự nhiên n à đương nhiên là
bây giờ Lạc quan là có các tài xế công
nghệ rồi Nên là nếu mà cảm thấy mà không
thoải mái thì có thể đặt tài xế về nhưng
mà ý tôi là nó vẫn nằm ở vi Khải niệm là
chủ động hay vì bị
động ví dụ
tôi tôi nói cái này nó nói cái tâm lý
chung ấy không phải về mỗi mối quan hệ
hẹn hò tình cảm hay là mối quan hệ bạn
bè đâu mà trong rất nhiều cái tôi nghĩa
là chủ động mình mình nắm thế chủ động
nó sẽ luôn tốt hơn chứ đúng không đấy
cái tự tin hay các thứ thứ đấy sẽ Nhược
cái đấy tựng Mình đang kìm hãm mình thôi
chứ không phải là người khác tác động
đến mình ví dụ Giả sử là kiểu bạn đưa ra
đưa ra những cái gì đó xong rồi người
khác phản bác khiến cho bạn tự ái bạn
kể không muốn làm điều đấy nữa về gì đó
thì nó đã khác Còn đây là bạn còn chư
thử Mà chư thử đúng không Nhưng mà mình
đã tự đưa ra những cái kiểu mình nghĩ là
ôi có khi nó sẽ tệ đấy mình thôi mình
không làm
thành ra là kiểu tự mình đang giới hạn
bản thân mình ở trong cái vùng mà rất
nhiều người sẽ nghĩ rằng là đấy là vùng
an toàn nhưng mà tôi đã từng nói rồi
không có khái niệm nào là vùng an toàn
cả tất cả những cái gì mà các bạn đang
nghĩ là đang rất là chắc chắn đang rất
là an toàn
thì nó nó chỉ là cái tâm lý của các bạn
đ nghĩ là nó an toàn thôi Thế làm gì có
gì thực sự an toàn chẳng có cái gì là
mãi mãi cả đúng không ạ đấy Cái gì nó
cũng sẽ thay đổi với với cái tôi Tôi cảm
thấy là
tôi Tôi cảm thấy là tôi được may mắn như
bây giờ tôi được cố gắng đ bây giờ vì
tôi cảm thấy là tôi cũng kiểu gọi là th
thích nghi được cái sự thay đổi đấy để
tôi kiểu khi khi gặp vấn đề gì đó thì
mình biết cách xử lý mình kiểu biết là
xoay truyện tình huống nếu mà bạn gặp
tôi ngoài đời rồi thấy tôi lên kế hoạch
nào đó đị rồi đấy mà khi mà có gì đó xảy
ra tôi vẫn biết cách để Xẽ sợ được tôi
vẫn lên lên lạc quan để mà thay đổi được
tình huống thì Đấy mình nên chủ động
trong rất nhiều cái đấy chứ mình hạn chế
mình bị động Ui bị thế rồi làm sao bây
giờ thôi thế Thế thì cuộc sống nó thay
đổi nhiều lắm bạn phải xác định Tôi
tưởng là cuộc sống nó sẽ biến động liên
tục đúng không mình mà có quan điểm là
muốn mọi thứ nó được như cũ mọi thứ ở
trong vùng an toàn thì là sai nó chỉ
thực sự an toàn khi mà bạn đã sẵn sàng
mọi cho cái mọi thứ nó có thể xảy ra đấy
mới gọi là an toàn
bạn chí là một cái bẫy tâm lý thôi Bởi
vì nếu mà Nó đùng phát nó thay đổi nó
không còn như bạn nghĩ nữa thì bạn là
đứa gục ngã đầu tiên đúng không ạ Không
ai đánh gục bạn cả tự bạn lừa bạn bạn là
nó sẽ thế thành ra là kể tự bạn thụ ngã
thôi Đúng rồi th ra khái niệm tự nhiên ấ
cái từ tự nhiên ấ nó là để thể hiện việc
là giống kiểu thiên nhiên ấ ng nó thay
đổi nó nó sẽ thay đổi khôn lường đúng
không Không ai vô thường đúng không
Không ai lường trước được Đấy mới gọi là
từ tự khái niệm chuẩn của từ tự nhiên
đừng có nghĩa V việc là tự nhiên nó sẽ
không vờ thay đổi đúng không
ạ Tôi không nói việc là bạn cần phải cái
gì gì đó tôi đương nhiên là đang nói
theo vẫn là góc độ cá nhân của tôi mà
đang nói là với tôi khái niệm an toàn là
như thế và và tôi nghĩ
là mình nên làm mọi thứ mà mình cảm thấy
là Ừ thứ nhất mình nên làm này Thứ hai
là mình sẽ về sau sẽ không ân hận này ân
hận ở đây sẽ gồm hai cái ân hận vì đã
làm và ân hận vì không làm bỏ lỡ này
Đấy và giống như tôi vừa nói về cái fomo
đúng không Đừng nghĩ là bây giờ là quá
muộn hay là đừng nghĩ là mình sẽ bị bỏ
lỡ gì đó ví dụ bây giờ cứ cho là nếu mà
có ông nào đó mới tím một tí kiểu cô cho
là tín hiệu Vũ Trụ hay gì đó tôi rất
thích mấy ông nào thử nhắc thấy tín hiệu
vũ trụ đấy Kiểu cái thệ dấu hiệu Vũ Trụ
hay tín hiệu gì đó đấy tôi sẽ được đà để
nói ông đấy là đấy đ
vũ trụ cử tao đến nói cho mày những cái
điều này đ mày được Mày tỉnh ngộ đi đấy
Cái thứ hay mà đặc
biệt kiểu Hơi tí mở mồm ra tín hiệu vũ
trụ tôi Thỉnh thoảng tát mấy cái đứa th
anh nói tín hiệu vũ trụ nữa tôi bảo là
vũ trụ cử tao đến đ đánh mày mày không đ
quyền chấm cự gì
cả Ừ nhưng đại khái như thế cuộc sống
của bạn Do bạn làm chủ do bạn quyết định
mọi đầu tiên là phảy thay đổi góc nhìn
nhé từ góc nhìn sẽ dẫn đến Thái độ này
xong rồi hành vi này xong rồi thói quen
vân vân và thói quen đấy sẽ dần dần hình
thành con người bạn thôi ví dụ là ví dụ
Cứ cho là cái các bạn dễ liên tưởng nhất
với cái kiểu ngoại hình phải bề ngoài đi
là là kiểu tập chim thườ ví dụ đấy tầu
tiên thì mạ thay đổi gấp nhìn về tập gim
bạn thích đi tập GM đấy Bạn thấy nhiều
người xung quanh tập GM nó một điều bình
thường đấy x bạn cũng thử đi đấy bạn thử
đi xong rồi bạn đấy thay đổi thái độ
thay đổi quan điệm rồi đúng không xong
bạn đi dần dần Nó thành thói quen thói
quen rồi thì bạn sẽ đi nhiều thì cơ thể
bạn sẽ đẹp hơn bởi vì là nó nó phải bề
ngoài n thay đổi bạn nhìn được mà Đấy
dần dần bạn đẹp hơn rồi thì bạn lại càng
muốn đi hơn đấy vân vân th dần dần về
sau bạn sẽ có một cơ thể kiểu Tý tưởng
như bạn muốn đấy thì rõ ràng là thay đổi
từ cái nhỏ dần dần khi mà thành thói
quen rồi nó
sẽ nó sẽ Tác động lớn đúng không và cuộc
sống mình sẽ khác đúng không Ok tiếp nhỉ
ờ đồ
Xiaomi để nói như này nhỉ Ừ Đầu tiên
thì tôi
Tôi là một người tôi không biết tôi có
tôi chắc chắn không phải một người kiểu
ít mua sắm tôi vẫn thừa nhận tôi là
người vẫn hay mua rất nhiều đồ bao gồm
đó đồ si mi vì tôi cảm thấy thích cái
hãng này điểm nó nó đi lên từ
đồ đồ kiểu gia dụng ý h nó có lắm đồ V
trưng tôi mua làm đồ V Trưởng xong rồi
Tôi cảm thấy là tôi nên tính của tôi là
hạ kiểu không thích không thích khó tìm
hiểu về mấy cái kiểu những cái thứ mình
phải chuyên ấy không phải kiểu ngồi lướt
lướt này ngồi canh giảm giá ngồi canh
các thứ thứ thành ra
là nói chung là hạ không không phải con
người mà kiểu đam mê mua sản mình thế
chẳng qua là cũng khi bây giờ mình có
tài chính có điều kiện một tí thì tôi
cũng muốn sắm gì đó ra đình đấy Tôi nghĩ
là tính tôi cầu toàn cẩn thận tô tôi tự
đánh giá thế nên này là tôi sẽ sắm nhấy
cái đồ mà tôi nghĩ là nó cần thiết
đấy th và thằng Xiaomi thì có rất nhiều
đồ tôi mua làm nhiều cực luôn đấy và đến
bây giờ để mà đánh giá lại
là tôi kiểu khan trong thòng một cái gì
đó vài hãng gì đó giống như điển hình
nhá quần áo thì mặc unicol này đấy đồ
giáo dụng Ở nhà mọi đồ có thể thì mua
của Xiaomi này từ điện thoại Ờ tôi liệt
cây dà nhiều lắm đại khái Thì Ừ đúng
là nó chỉ được ngon
rẻ còn độ bền thì nó nhên là có vài
cái đến bây giờ tôi vẫn dùng được tôi sẽ
đánh giá nó góc độ như này nh
nhá là tôi hỏng đến cái cái tăm nước thứ
hai rồi nên TH là tôi sẽ mua hẳn cái
hãng khác rồi Kiểu thế những đồ khác thì
chưa học th Tôi nghĩ là nó sẽ về sau mà
nó có vấn đề gì nó sẽ quan ngại
đấy còn à độ kiểu cò cách dùng thì nói
chung là tôi cứ chùm nó tôm Bảy đi đấy
Kiểu C thế rồi
và thực ra là tôi nghĩ
cái đồ mà kiểu cao cấp xịn hơn nhưng mà
Đúng là mình phải xác định
là hạn chế mua đồ lại Tại sao phải dùng
tướ như thế vì tôi từng nghĩ là tôi sẽ
mua mấy đồ này tôi sẽ dùng kiểu cả đời
nó hơi quá Nhưng tôi phải dùng đến kiểu
có gia đình kiểu lập có con các thứ các
thứ đồ này vẫn sẽ sẽ sái tốt ấy kiểu thế
nhưng mà không có vẻ có những cái đồ mà
kiểu bây giờ đúng R người ta Thiên là về
đồ Nói thẳng luôn Nói thẳng luôn là cứ
hết hạn bảo hành hay gì gì đó đồ sẽ có
vấn đề đấy nó không còn cái kiểu đồ nồi
đồng cối đá giống như là cái thời trước
nữa Bây giờ Bây giờ tôi thấy là có nhiều
nơi nó từng à Có nhiều từng kênh đã từng
nó nói m cái điều đấy Nó kiểu đồ công
nghệ Nói chung bây giờ Nó cố tình cố
tình để làm nó không được bền nữa để con
bán mà nó gọi là nh
là không phải văn hóa tiêu dùng đâu Tôi
quên Tôi từng hỏi bên các bạn một lần
rồi Nó là
cái cái từ chuyên ngành của nó V bên
kinh tế nó cái gì nh th tiêu dùng
nha chủ nghĩa tiêu dùng đấy nghĩa là đồ
nó sẽ lúc nào lúc nào kiểu xung quanh
cái truyền thông hay làm mọi thứ để cảm
thấy mình có vẻ mình cần mấy cái đồ này
Đấy nó Nó kiểu nó thao túng mình ấy đúng
không Đấy xong rồi và làm cho mình phải
sắm rất là nhiều đồ đấy rồi cái thứ hai
là m đồ đấy không hề bền không còn bề
nữa mà chỉ mỗi năm nó ra tượ vài cái thu
hút mình có vẻ mình CN nâng cấp lên thử
đển hình Nhất là cái điện thoại thôi còn
thấy là bây giờ điện thoại bão hòa lắm
rồi chưa Rõ ràng
là là kiểu mấy năm rồi đổi Ở đây chẳng
thấy có gì khác biệt C nóm thêm cái gập
chứ mấy đấy Kiểu thế nó không còn cái gì
đó Kiểu mình đáng phải lên nữa nhưng mà
Đấy cái cái con tôi không biết được ở về
sau Xiaomi mà không biết về sao mình có
nổi tiếng nh chắc không đâu em mà bị nó
sẽ tỉnh nó sẽ kiểu thể trai mình hay gì
gì đó đại khái Tôi dùng
con Xiaomi 13t này nó không phải
flagship nhưng mà nó cũng là mức tầm
trung ấy tôi thấy là tôi mua từ đầu năm
nay lúc là nó mới ra mắt luôn Tôi vẫn
nhớ là Cái hôm mà tôi mua người ta còn
xin chụp ảnh tôi thì tôi khách hàng đầu
tiên mua cơ
đấy đến bây giờ
thì nó đã có dấu hiệu là kiểu
thỉnh thoảng lag rồi lag đến nỗi phải
máy rồi đấy nên tôi đã cảm thấy Vi đồ
công nghệ rồi Nó đang rất có vấn đề à
Vẫn đang nói riêng mỗi Xiaomi thôi vể
tôi đấy Đang cố làm fan trung thành của
một cái có vẻ là ok có vấn
đề nên hôm trướcc tôi có hỏi là kiểu hỏi
thăm dò anh em là anh em có dùng nhiều
Pixel không x không bàn chính hãng ở
Việt Nam Nó rất là cấn Tôi vẫn đang
không biết là nên thay điện thoại như
thế nào tuy nhiên tôi có một con iPhone
dùng song song rồi nên là không thể bảo
chuyển qua hẳn iPhone
được sẽ có người bảo tôi dùng Samsung
nhưng mà tôi có cái gì đó Tôi không
thích hàng Samsung lắm bạn kia xung pha
nà tôi không thức
lắm Ừ chắc là nếu mà bây giờ tô thay đổi
điện thoại một là
xom mi tiếp lên hẳn flashship xem thế
nào hai là t sắm n Pixel
đấy ba là thực ra là hồi trước đã tình
nghĩ là có
thể Sony Nhưng mà thực ra là Sony tôi
thấy là người ta chỉ đánh giá một cái
camera mà tôi lại không phải là người
chụp ảnh Hiều không biết
nào À đấy thì tại sao tôi lại phải chia
sẻ một cái điều này không phải chia sẻ
mới cái mỗi điều này là kiểu để giãi bày
cái tấm lòng tôi đâu Tôi nghĩ là tôi
đang đại diện đấy tôi có để chia sẻ ở mô
tả của kênh của tôi ấ và tôi đại diện
diện cho một thế hệ hay một cái gì đó
được Tôi nghĩ là ai cũng có thể đã từng
trải qua một cái góc phần nào đó và đặc
biệt đặc biệt và có có vài người mà
xem tôi từ thời gian mà họ còn đang là
sinh viên
đấy họ họ
kiểu kém tôi chỉ một hai tuổi thôi đấy
thì tôi gần như là một người tôi vẫn
luôn muốn mình là một người Tiên Phong
đi trước chia sẻ lại cái gì thì chia sẻ
được để mà các bạn đỡ giống như anh độ
nói là đỡ ngủ à Tôi trải qu Anh đội từng
nói câu gì nh lúc bị mất ní nhỉ tôi ngu
để ch các bạn đỡ bị dính phải không hiểu
chính xác câu này lắm cơ đã khái này tôi
bị mắc mắc cái tôi mắc sai lầm để các
bạn đỡ phải phạm phải đỡ tốn tiền oan
này hay gì gì đó tôi sẽ chia sẻ những
cái kểu bài học đáp giá của của của tôi
đấy để mà các bạn có thể tham
cũng có hệ sinh thái Thực ra lý tưởng
nhất của tôi thấy nó phải là Huawei một
tỗ Huawei nó bán không chính hãng tay
Việt Nam thôi Samsung tôi th cũng có hệ
sinh thái Nhưng mà thực ra Samsung đồ
đắt hơn của Xiaomi nhá nên tôi một phần
tôi cũng ngại quan ngại việc đấy để mà
tôi sắm hết đồ của cả hệ sinh thái
Samsung thì đắt lắm Có mỗi thằng bạn
thôi nó mới dám chơi thế thôi nhưng mà
tôi từng thấy thằng bạn tôi sau một thời
gian chơi hệ sinh thái của Samsung nó
vẫn chuyển qua quay lại dùng iPhone ạ
Thế nên thế là tôi cảm thấy là có khi là
theo hệ sinh thái Samsung không là một
cái bước tiến hay
ờ nhà là thì có điều kiện mà đi chơi hệ
sinh thái hết của
cuối Tôi nói chuyện mấy ông với khái
niệm nhà mặt đất so với chung cư đối với
tôi Tôi đã từng nói mấy ông là có khi
tôi sẽ hối Hồi trước thì tôi từng nghĩ
là tôi sẽ mua nhà chung cư hoặc là thuê
nhà kiểu thế bởi vì còn chưa biết chưa
biết là mình sẽ cố định ở đâu Ví dụ ví
dụ là
mình mình định vào trong Đà Nẵng kia kìa
đấy nên ở nhà mặt đất sao được Đấy mình
nên kể thuê các thứ thứ à đương nhiên là
tôi vẫn đang nói chung nhá Tôi còn chưa
biết vợ tôi bây giờ sau này là ai mà
biết đâu gặp được Phú Bà Nà đó mà để khá
Bạn ấy thích ở đâu nữa vân vân rất nhiều
yếu tố nĩ là tôi nghĩa Thế là tôi chưa
chắc chắn được tôi sẽ từng nghĩ việc
là thuê nhà chung cư sau đó thì cái hồi
mà xem được cái một cái clip Ở trên
tiktok có một bạn hát Mỗ dàn Ok chất
lượng nghe hay vậy chưa Mà tôi là một
người rất là mê hát V Tôi cảm thấy là ừ
có khi phải mua nhà mặt đất và nó nên ở
bên Long Biên Tại sao ở Long Biên vì
nhất là bên đấy Kiểu vẫn đang còn vẫn
đang kiểu Ừ không đông đúc lắm tể là
mình có thể nhà mình có thể không bị ồn
sang hàng xóm tôi rất ghét làm ảnh hưởng
đến xung quanh
đấy thì à đươ nhiên là cũng làm nên cách
âm tí thì đấy định mua nhà mặt đất nhưng
mà bên mạn mạn kiểu kiểu thế đấy và Long
ttinh Yên nữa thay vì ở kiểu nam từ Liên
hay Bắc Từ Liên Bởi vì tôi cảm thấy là
đi từ bên đầy sang Trung tâm nó vẫn gần
tiện hơn đấy đấy tôi tính là như thế
chưa biết được cho đến khi gần đây gần
đây tôi đợt mùa bóng vừa rồi Xin chúc
mừng mình đã bị mất con xe đạp nhảy Mất
con xe
đạp con xe đạp cũng là xe đạp Xiaomi
luôn đấy thầy Tiến Đồ Xiaomi chưa đấy
thì tôi đang ở khu tập thể thì tôi có để
con xe đạp đấy khóa xích lại vào trong
cái chân cầu Tha bởi vì thấy Bởi
vì bởi vì kiểu Ờ không Tôi ngại gửi xe ở
dưới
ngại có bãi xe ở dưới là bãi xe máy
đâ xích vào nhưng có vẻ là bị nhảy mất
không biết được là như nào đấy Có cam
nhưng mà cũng nhìn chẳng ra được cái gì
và tôi cảm thấy tôi thử lên trí báo thì
bảo là khó lấy vì nó liên quan đến số
không xe máy có s số khung xe đạp Chẳng
có gì cả n thôi C như
là chịu vậy Cho dù là tôi thời đấy tôi
cũng máu vì tôi còn à Tôi cũng định máu
kiểu điều tra các thứ à Bởi vì h ấy xem
nhiều phim Vượt Ngục nh
không Mấy ông không biết mấy ông xem
phim Vượt Ngục kia như đại cái các thám
tử ấy kiểu ngồi điều tra thử tính th suy
nghĩ kìu Nếu nếu
là nếu là kiểu tội phạm thì họ sẽ có
những suy nghĩ nào đấy t cả các thứ các
thứ người không hình dung không đấy đươ
nhiên là tội phạm trong phim nó còn
thông minh các thử thử thá tử thô còn
phức tạp như thế ngoài đời này th mình
mà kiểu có cái IQ kiểu cao như thế chắc
chắn mình tìm là được ngay dễ hơn tôi
nghĩ là dễ hơn không phải khó như là
trong phim vật ngục đâu nh cũng không
phải khó như Conan đâu đấy nhưng mà tôi
nghĩ là nó không đáng nó nó có giá trị
đấy nhưng mẹ ý tôi là kì
tháo xử hết rồi không biết được vân vân
n là thôi đh vậy nhưng mà đấy chỉ một
cái nhỏ đấy lại Làm tôi nghĩa là quay
quay xe sang bên nhà chung cư vì tôi cảm
thấy
là nhà nhà đất hay là nhà khu tập thuê
nó liên quan rất nhiều đến an ninh nó sẽ
chỉ có ưu điểm tôi cảm thấy nó ưu điểm
đối với tôi quan điểm nha Đó là phải
tránh nổ thôi nghe chiếm mình chẳng
không bị ảnh hưởng tháng Xóm Lắm nhảy ra
khỏi nhà mình nhanh hơn việc mình đợi
thang máy hoặc là mình chạy bộ từ cố
đáng xuống chứ đúng không
đấy nhưng an ninh thì tôi cảm thấy nó có
vẻ cần đấy n về sau bất kỳ có vấn đề gì
coi như tự mình sửa tự mình phả xử
lý đấy là khái niệm về nhà mặt đất đấy
là vẫn là góc nhìn của tôi hiện tại thôi
Tôi nghĩ là nó thêm một cái bài học trải
nghiệm gì đó để mà mình suy nghĩ cân
tôi từng biết nhiều gia
đình dùng từ dòng họ luôn được xung
quanh toàn nhà họ hàng nhau Tôi có biết
vụ đấy Nhưng mà thường là kiểu như ở
làng quê hoặc là đấy đất nhà bạn rộng
thôi chứ còn ở Hà Nội gi khó mà làm được
cái điều
nữa đùa đấy thế ra thì ngoài công việc
ra thì người thân mọi thứ của tôi vẫn
còn trên này
mà tôi định lên thì sẽ Xiaomi 14 Thôi
tôi không ý định chụp ảnh lắm cho D Tôi
nhớ là cái thời mà tôi mua con điện
thoại Xiaomi này Và thậm chí là mua con
iPhone kia có mua con iPhone kia là còn
tôi định Quay vlog nhiều cho anh em ấy
nhưng
mà một phần là lời chục lời quay kết hợp
việc lời Chỉnh sửa kết hợp nữa là việc
là như tôi nói là tôi vẫn thấy mình chưa
đủ chín mồi để mà để
Vlog đầu tiên của tôi nó vẫn gì ấn
được mà Ừ anh tôi biết là Trung phư vẫn
làm được nhiều cái nhưng mà hám chỉ là
nó không phải là của mình hoàn toàn trừ
khi mua đứt nhưng mà cái đấy còn cấn hơn
nên đại khái
là tôi có nghĩ về cái đấy khá nhiều kiểu
Nhiều người bảo có thể mua studio à Xong
rồi tự sửa lại theo ý mình à vân vân đã
khái này rồi Nếu mà nhà của mình Mình tự
sửa rất nhiều cái nó hơn đấy đúng
không n là tôi có c nhắc về cái
đấy Em thích dùng iPhone ở chỗ đổ qua
máy chỉ cần đăng nhập là đồng bộ hết các
thử
Thế nhá Tôi chả
cũng cũng chưa thấy đấy Một ưu
Vào setting để tôi ngồi xem từng cái một
ấy thì tôi cảm thấy là nó có hơn setting
gì So cái cũ Tôi làm thế ngay từ hồi con
máy đầu tiện đầu tiên tôi có chắc phải
từ hồi cứ cho cấp hai đi đấy tôi ngồi mò
rồi Thậm chí là hồi đấy đương nhiên là
chưa mò nỗi là cái rom này hay là
kiểu mở nhưng mà về sau cũng biết cách
mò để mở ra một cái phần cài đặt của nhà
phát triển của developer ấy đấy Tôi nghĩ
là đấy là một trong những cái mà hình
thành cá thói quen thích mò Mẫn thích
kiểu không ngại bị học tôi từng có điện
loại hỏng cũng có máy tính hỏng có nế
chắc là làm được ngành IT cũng chắc là
phần thế Tôi từng nói V mấy ông cái đấy
rồi nó chỉ là tôi không lại mà mò Tìm
tìm tòi à đương nhiên giờ đỡ hơn rồi à
không phải phải đỡ mà bây giờ bị hạn chế
thôi Nhiều lúc tôi Lười quá tôi muốn
dùng sẵn một cái vài cái thôi Nhưng mà
mình vẫn phải có cái đầu mở đúng không ạ
Thế mấy ông mới thấy tôi đang dùng s này
hay dùng chom à Dùng vs code hay vì dùng
quen thuộc cái pp Storm đúng không đ Tôi
đang thay đổi kiểu thử thêm nhiều góp
nhìn
nghĩ là sẽ có đấy có bạn gần đây cũng
lâu lắm tôi mới nói chuyện với người bạn
đấy vì người bạn đấy người bạn từ hồi
đại học của tôi anh em cũng có sức Mịch
hối trước nên thành ra gần đây mới nói
chuyện thân lại Thì ông đấy cũng có máy
chơi game ở nhà chơi game offline luôn
đấy tôi có ý định là sẽ khi mà Ờ nhưng
mà phải phải phải Build một con PC để
chơi game offline mấy cái đấy chứ con
laptop này không chơi được đâu Tôi có ý
định
đấy tôi livestream chơi Nói chung là tôi
livestream chơi game hay tôi livestream
làm tất cả những cái điều này ấ và tôi
muốn
kiểu nó sẽ kiểu m thiên hướng vừa tôi
chia sẻ cái góc nhìn của
tôi để cho những ai mà có cùng góc nhìn
đấy hoặc tông trả thì cảm thấy đông cảm
có người Ừ thì ít ra có một người n n dẫ
mình nên là tôi sẽ cố tạo cảm giác gần
gũi nhất và cảm giác kiểu à Tự nhiên
nhất để mấy ông cảm thấy là nó kiểu tôi
cũng chỉ là một người bình thường thôi
để mấy ông hoàn toàn thể tâm sự hoặc là
chia sẻ đấy và chơi game cũng sẽ thế chứ
tôi không hướng đ kiểu là phải theo
phong trào nào kểu dả như các anh các
anh livestream đi trước thì mấy ông thấy
hiện nhiên n rất nhiều anh nổi từ Chơi
game hoặc rất nhiều Anh Nội bị tâm sự
hay là làm những cái gì đó ghê gớm tôi
không không ý định phát triển theo kiểu
như thế để mấy anh ấy còn chơi game theể
yêu cầu gì gì đâu C tôi thì tôi nghĩ chỉ
chơi những cái mà tôi thích thôi ấ thậm
chí là phải quay lại VAP chẳng hạn một
thời tuổi
thơ có thể cầy VAP mãi được
tự tự tạo Custom map đấy chơi này vui mà
nói chung là
kiểu định hướng của tôi nó sẽ kiểu như
thế cơ chứ không phải
là chơi những game kinh
dị xong rồi gà H hay gì đó hay là có mấy
anh văn thơ live láng luôn Vừa chơi game
vừa có thể xuất khẩu thành thơ Cái đấy
là tôi chịu
Cái đấy là đối với tôi thân tượng với
cái người xa bơi
nhất năm HA Anh có chơi game không ạ
chơi T bé tí cơ kể mấy ông tôi động động
máy tính vé tí chơi hồi hai tuổi rồi gạ
à Có vài người đây chắc là người mới thi
không biết
đi
Ừ th ra tôi còn đang cảm thấy cái chuyến
đấy nó sẽ bị xoay chong chóng chứ không
phải là một cái thứ mà mình đã chuẩn bị
tốt để mình thể quay cái gì đó chắc là
thôi vẫn chưa Sẵn sàng mấy cái điều
đấy đây Uầy hơn một tiếng đ ngồi rồi
mình vẫn chỉ dừng ở mới cái tâm sự
ạ Chưa trả lời đống câu hỏi kia thế là
câu hỏi này là câu hỏi những cái cũ đã
từng trả lời rồi mấy cái mới này này
trả lời trước mấy cái mới và mấy cái cũ
kia thì chắc là sẽ có thời gian nào đó
Trả lời Sau hôm n có gì không kịp nói
một lúc khản rộng
Ờ đừng để mình thành lựa
ghi nó lại
nhớ được tôi sẽ ché gió ra có đề ấy mình
à Chào em à Đấy anh sắp vào Đà Nẵng Đấy
Chú cứ chuẩn bị đi Đ nhá kéo đúng một
háng nữa luôn đấy một hàng nữa em
Đừng đừng vể tự nhiên là tôi cảm thấy là
nếu mà tôi xuất H từ một cái đề bài này
tôi ra được hẳn cái đoạn băn để chén
chục tậ đá lẽ là hồi đấy điểm Văn tôi
phải cao lắm à
này ấ
vì cái cái tôi nói về cái đường cùng chứ
nhá
bạn bạn cùng tấm tuổi tôi bạn khôngi tầm
tui bằng tuổi tôi hôm trước mới mới phải
đi vay tiền tựng nhiên là bao gồm cả tôi
Tôi hỗ trợ được bạn đấy nhưng có những
những người khác thì không Bạn cũng tâm
sự với tôi điều
đấy đương nhiên là gia đình bạn đã có
chuyện bạn ấy phải làm rất nhiều thứ để
xoay
à Tôi cảm thấy là tôi chỉ giúp được một
phần thôi vì tôi từng khuyên bạn ấy
nhiều cái nhưng mà bạn đấy có thể bị
thiếu độ lực hay vì rất nhiều yếu tố
khác mà tôi không biết nên là thánh g
bạn ấy
vẫn vẫn kiểu bị bị cuộc đời đẩy kiểu thế
chứ bạn ấy không tự làm chủ được cuộc
đời bạn đấy
đấy đại khái là
ờ hồi trước tôi bị trừa đại học giống hệ
cùng bạn đấy th hai đứa tầm tuổi nhau x
rồi hai đứa cùng rủ nhau đi nộp hồ sơ
vào Đại học khác vân vân cô đi tìm đại
học cũng cả hai cùng theo ngành công
nghệ tin đấy đấy không được tính là bạn
thân tôi nhưng cũng là bạn kể cũng chơi
lâu và đặc biệt là cũng chơi game cùng
các thứ thế đấy đấy ông đấy cũng là một
trong những người mà tôi cảm thấy rất
rất rỏ tư duy Đình Cực
đấy nên là tôi thấy rất là tiếc khi mà
bạn đấy
à không theo được cái ngành không tin
này và bây giờ bạn ấy đang nhìn tôi cho
kiểu là thỉnh thoảng Bạn ấy vẫn nhắn nhờ
tôi giúp bạn ấy không phải về tiền nhá
mà kểu bảo là muốn học tại công nghệ
thông tin để mà muốn học lại làm lại từ
đầu ấy bởi vì bây giờ rất nhiều lúc là
bạn ấy phải đi chạy đi những công việc
nói tránh nhanh thì nó còn sang ấy nó
thẳng luôn là kiểu đi làm kiểu bôi bàn
hoặc là chạy RP hay các th thứ công việc
nó chẳng liên quan đế chết xám gì cả đấy
mà tư duy bạn đấy rất là giỏi đến bây
giờ bạn vẫn giỏi đấy tôi cảm thấy là
kiểu không biết là đồng đầy bạn đẩy bạn
ấy Tại sao bạn ấy thành như thế rất vực
là bạn ấy không có khả năng tập trung
vào để học để cố gắng đượ tôi bà Ừ thì
tôi cũng chia sẻ kênh của tôi là có dạy
hập trình cơ bản để bạn đã học qua cũng
như là cũng như là kiểu
à tự học cái gì Thì đó khác Bạn ấy hứng
Nội hơn tôi rất nhiều và khả năng tự học
bạn ấy theo tôi là phải hơn tôi nhưng có
vẻ là là vì rất nhiều ý tố cả khả năng
tập trung hay gì gì đó hay không có động
lực hay gì đó Tôi không biết nhưng mà
Đấy Và bây giờ khi mà bạn ấy gặp
chuyện Vì nếu mà khi mà đến tầm tuổi tôi
bây giờ tôi 27 rồi đấy thì đáng lẽ là
công việc mọi thứ và tương đối ổn định
rồi và phải có tiềm ít nhất phải có tiềm
dành dụng ra một ít rồi Để khi gặp một
cái biến cố nào đó như này thì mình có
tiền để ra để xoay còn không Bạn ấy đang
bị kiểu cuộc đời đẩy mà nên là làm được
ngày nào sống được ngày đấy thôi như khi
có vấn đề xảy ra này bạn không có một
đồng nào để xoay sợ điều đấy cả nên là
bạn đấy phải đi
chạy bán hết mọi thứ rất nhiều cái từ
điện thoại cả xe
đấy Thế nên tôi mới ghi lại những cái
điều này đó là không bao giờ được để
mình để mình vào con đường cung lúc đấy
không ai cứu được bạn cả tôi là một
người còn không thân với bạn đấy tôi còn
C cố hỗ trợ bạn đấy còn bạn thân của bạn
đấy Bạn ấy có nói là ông ấy gọi ông đấy
ông ấy không nghe May đấy biết biết được
là sẽ nhiều V không nghe tôi còn chưa
biết được là là ông ấy ông
kia gặp chuyện gì gia đình đại khái là
tôi chỉ biết được là nó là một cái thứ
mà đến chính tôi
cũng không biết Giúp kiểu gì
ý thì rõ ràng là họ vẫn chỉ tự họ cứu họ
được thôi rất nhiều lúc tôi từng đây
không phải trường hợp đầu tiên tự nhiên
tôi nếu V trường hợp mỗi trường hợp đầu
tiên và trường hợp duy nhất thì theo
trường hợp V kiểu cá biển thì tôi chẳng
cần phải ngồi chia sẻ mấy ông đây làm gì
cả Tôi cảm thấy là tôi đã gặp được
trường hợp này nhiều rồi và tôi cảm thấy
là rất nhiều lúc là mình chỉ cần thiếu
một tí kiên nhẫn mình kểu mình nghĩ là
thôi mình Bây giờ vẫn đang ổn Đấy vẫn
cái vùng an toàn nào đó đấy đấy vẫn nghĩ
là mình đang an toàn đấy thành ra là
kiểu khi mà cuộc sống nó thay đổi cái
biến cố nà đó thì thôi mình là lựa mình
mình bị đẩy đến đường cùng mình không
còn cách nào để xoay nó ra đúng không
ạ Thế nên là từ đầu năm nay khi mà tôi
đã có dư giả hơn về tài chính Nên tôi
cũng phải cân nhắc việc là Nếu giả sử mà
mình mà không không có khả năng lao động
hay không thể làm được công việc này nữa
đúng không ạ Đấy thì mình phải có một
cái gì đó thì bây giờ nó sẽ khái niệm
bảo hiểm đấy thôi có đi đầu tư bảo hiểm
à cái mấy câu chuyện này không phải điều
hướng mua bảo hiểm đâ nhá Không tôi
không nói n mua bảo hiểm hay không nói
hãng nào đừng bảo tôi lùa gá tôi đang
nói
là mình phải mình phải luôn có phương án
nào đó tôi đi đầu tư sang cả à Tôi mua
bảo hiểm như tôi không đầu tư mu bảo
hiểm nhân họ này đấy tôi đầu tôi có đầu
tư chí trí quỹ cả mua vàng C thứ vân vân
tôi biết được là
công việc hiện tại nó rất là ổn định chứ
Công việc hiện tại nó rất là sáng nhưng
mà tôi không bao giờ được để bản thân
mình ngủ quên trong một cái dịch cảm
đúng không ạ Đấy nên là bây giờ Tiền bây
giờ tôi đấy từ tí thưởng ấy Bây giờ có
Tề thưởng có để để đấy đi gửi ngân hàng
nói thẳng luôn gửi ngân hàng
nó lại suất mà nó không đủ
bằng lạm phát đúng không ạ nên
là Nên là chắc chắn là mình phải nghĩ
cái th gì
đó không biết được anh em đã đến cái
giai đoạn phải nghĩ như thế chưa đấy tôi
có nghĩ rồi thếu Như tôi cũng phải tôi
cũng để khoản lớn của tôi ở trong số
kiện ngân hàng có để mà Đấy sẽ là tiền
ăn chắc mặc bền à để lấy
vỡ đấy nhưng mà cũng phải nghĩ đương
nhiên là có cái chuẩn nhất mà ông biết
đầu tư là gì không Là đầu tư là bản thân
ông thình quyền để mà học hỏi lên để
nâng cấp bản thân hơn mua sách là một
người
chuyể ai cũng làm đấy tiếp theo là đấy
tôi tôi có liệt kê đống ở đây này không
biết mở lên về có bị dính cái gì không
đâ tôi tôi tôi xem lại một tí đã à đây
đây tôi có ghi thêm vài cái
này Đấy nói từ vào Đảng vào Đảng nó tốt
mà nó đúng không không không bị nhạy cảm
gì đúng không mặc dù kênh của tôi rất cố
né chính trị
nghĩ đến thế sau cái mình mình còn đang
độ tuổi lao động các th thứ mà đã nghĩ
thế sao vậy
tồi ưu cơ sở liệu và anh sang là về
à
về chuyên về design patton chuyên về cá
code các thứ đy nhiên anh sang cũng biết
về database
nữa à bên fa này là ft academy đấy học
một khóa cơ bản bên này để xem cách bên
này dậy như nào để mình mình đi dậy thôi
có tôi có đang nuôi em chó chứ em chó
này ngoan nếu mà ông xem tôi hồi trước
thì ông sẽ thấy con nhớ con chó cũ của
tôi nó hơ tí sủa tí tôi phải quay Ra
mắng nó em này ngoan ông sẽ không ba giờ
nghe thấy nó kêu gì cả
rồi đôi khi nó sẽ chỉ kiểu chạy lon ton
xuống dưới chân xong rồi nó ngồi nh đấy
Đợi mình chú ý đến nó đấy đ nghĩa là tôi
sẽ có vài anh em ở đây tôi nhớ có vào
đẳng rồi tôi sẽ phải nhắn tin riêng để
hỏi anh em về cái khái niệm này để nói
chung là tôi cũng muốn cống hiến các
thứ muốn cống hiến các thứ cho đất nước
và nghe anh em gần đây có chia sẻ là có
một ông làm bên vi heo nữa tôi nhớ hồi
trước ấn tượng tôi về Viettel nó là công
ty nhà nước à Nó là nhà nước công đội
thì nó sẽ hơi bị Hơi bị kiểu Hiêm khắc
một tí và nó khi bị khó bó một tí Tôi sợ
nhưng mà thấy là ông đây thấy nói là bên
đấy ông đấy Bên ông đấy thì mọi thứ
thoải mái hơn nhiều cũng ở quân đội cũng
có thậm chí là sau Quân ham các thứ nghe
xịn mà Đấy An em thấy ra tôi nghĩ là tôi
sẽ tham khảo mấy cái đấy và nên vào Đảng
sớm ấ nhỉ đúng
không Không công ty tôi không yêu cầu
Tiếm Trung đâu Mấy cái này tôi định học
thêm đấy Kiểu định sang năm năm nay thì
đi trong nước này sang năm nhất định tôi
phải sang nước ngoài Trung và Thái piano
này hồi đấy học đang học giở xong rồi
không học được nữa lời bỏ
ghi vào chứ đy tất cả mới chỉ dừng lại
mức ý tưởng
Ờ cái lựa chọn này thì đương nhiên là nó
sẽ nó n ná giống như là kiểu từ việc
trong chuyện tình cảm trong chuyện yêu
trong chuyện à công
việc và trong việc bạn bè cũng thế
đừng bao giờ biến mình thành thứ mà
người ta phải bắn đo suy nghĩ xem nà có
nên đuổi thằng này không nhỉ Có nên hang
chức của nó không nhỉ Có nên chơi với
thằng này không nhỉ Kiểu kiểu thế Mà hãy
luôn kiểu Tôi nghĩ là phải tạo một cái
điểm nhấn ở đó ấn tượng ở đó Mấy ông đấy
lại đề cập về việc là vùng an toàn và
cái tự ti kia của mấy ông khi mấy ông tự
ti quá Mấy ông không nổi bật được bản
thân mình lên cho người khác biết được
mình là con người như thế nào
thì thành ra là người kia mình bị vô
hình trong trong kiểu trí nhớ người kia
luôn chứ không phải cho mắt luôn đấy
thành ra là khi có bất kỳ cái
gì họ sẽ không nhớ mình thậm chí là
chẳng nhớ mình dù mình đi chơi Chẳng hạn
chẳng ấn tượng gì chẳng nhớ Nó là đứa
nào
đấy nếu mà lúc mà lúc mà đuổi việc ấy
thường người ta không Không nhớ thể đuổi
đâu mà người ta sẽ kiểu xem lại cái danh
sách nhân viên rồi xong rồi đọp tên hàng
ngày xong rồi ấn tượng nó là gì tao nhớ
tao chẳng có ấn tượng gì với nó cả thế
mà đuổi đâu Thì Không ấ tượng thì chắc
là không có gì quan trọng
đâu là không không
nên không nên để mình thành những cái
lựa chọn
kiểu bị thành Nhữ cái lựa chọn kiểu tệ
hại như thế Vân Vân đúng không ạ Đấy nên
là theo tôi ai không ai được không ai cả
mà không mình nên tạo một cái dấu ấn
riêng mình phải xác định được mình muốn
trở thành con người như nào tạo một cái
dấu ấn riêng nào đó đấy Ok ạ tiếp thôi
ui hôm này ngồi tầm sự này tầm sự vài
ngày mới hết mất cái cái gì nhỉ Tôi
không nhớ mấy cái này đâu em sẽ trở
thành ai trong n
à mếu nghe được mà đúng không
ạ Em nghĩ nó hơi bị xa vợ nó không thực
tế đối với em mình là độc nhất mình cũng
là khác biệt nhất mình không việc gì
mình phải bắt chước ai hết bởi vì con
người mình nó được tạo từ những cái câu
chuyện riêng của mình từ những cái trải
nghiệm riêng của mình mình chỉ có thể
mình nói được rằng là liệu 5 năm của
mình mình có tốt lên không Mình có lớn
hơn được Chừng nào không cái suy nghĩ
của mình nó có trưởng thành hơn không
Thỉnh thoảng mình có có những cái sân si
này kia trong xã hội thì liệu 5 năm tới
mình có thực sự mình freedom không Mình
có nó không ảnh hưởng đến như vậy không
kiểu vậy em chỉ quan tâm đến cái cái
Grow của bản thân thôi vì em tin rằng là
tất cả những cái gì trong cuộc sống nó
đều đến với bản thân mình ấy khi mà mình
khi mà mình trở nên tốt hơn thì những
cái mối quan hệ xung quanh của mình tốt
hơn đấy thế là một cái kiểu chia sẻ của
thân tượng th tôi có nhưu thầ tượng lắm
nên thôi đại khái thế kiểu Tôi cảm thấy
là đây Đây là lần đầu tôi nghe anh ấy
nói chia sẻ mấy điều này
thần tượng đúng những cái người mà cùng
cùng cái kểu cùng định hướng à gì gì đó
tôi đã từng khuyên mấy mấy ông về mấy
cái điều này rồi đúng không ạ À đúng rồi
s s cái vụ s x gạt tay kia chắc 5 năm
trước
đấy nhưng
kiểu Tôi cảm thấy là rất nhiều lúc mình
mình đang đi đúng hướng đấy Mình đang đi
đúng hướng khi mà những cái thần tượng
của mình cũng nói ra những cái mà mình
quan điểm N là giống mình chứng tỏ là
mình đang đi đúng hướng không phải đi
đúng hướng là kiểu im theo thần tượng
đâu mà là mình vẫn phải đi con đường
riêng của mình nhưng mà
nhưng mà họ đang mất bảo cho mình những
cái điều đúng đắng là mình đang đúng Để
mình còn đi tiếp đúng không ạ tự tin đi
tiếp chảng ngại gì cả đúng không
Ừ Thực ra là hồi trước anh kiểu anh có
thể hướng ngoại như này thôi chứ hồi từ
hồi cấp một cho đến lên đến
ờ lên đến cấp ba
nhiều người vẫn đánh giá anh là người
Hống Nội vì anh chẳng giao tiếp với anh
có nói chuyện nhưng mà anh ch nói chuyện
tầp một nhóm người ở trong lớp anh không
hể biết được lớp bên ngoài như thế nào
như lên đại học cũng
thế nhưng mà đại khái còn tham gia được
nhiều hơn tí nên là lớp bên ngoài còn
khó biết đại khái là kiểu anh không phải
anh hướng ngoại từ bé nhá Anh không phải
không ngại anh không phải là ngại gặp
hay nói chuyện V khác đâu mà mình không
biết mình nói gì cơ đấy Đấy là điệu cấn
vân
vân các bạn sẽ rất nhiều lúc thấy tôi
như một người Hương
nội tôi gặp các bạn là
tôi Tôi nghĩ là tôi cần phải nói như tôi
mới nói nhiều chứ rất nhiều lúc bạn các
bạn sẽ thấy là tôi đi những cái kiểu tôi
đi Nói chuyện đặc biệt là người hơn tuổi
tôi biết được người ta đang cần nói n
tôi sẽ không nói gì cả Không xem vào cứ
cứ ngồi nghe thôi ấ người ta cứ tưởng
thôi nói ít hay vân vân
đấy anh hướng nội như bạn nữ nào thì anh
cũng quen không không không cùng lắm thì
đúng rồi Tôi có stack stack stack biết
đúng nhở
stack trả
được mà
st đấy có st đúng không Đấy đặc biệt là
lướt mấy thông tin
của các bạn đấy các thứ các thứ vân
bắt chuyện nhiều
thế tiếp không nhở à đây Tôi để lại cái
video này à à cả một video của đ nữa còn
đang xem gi Đợi tí tôi mở trên
video video này xem xong rồi video này
nhanh
và một video
nữa video này Đây của bạn Quỳnh Như ở
bên vật V studio đấy lại chia sẻ u xem
hay ch rất bánh cuốn rất Tôi khuyên mấy
ông nên xem vào lúc ăn hoặc là trước khi
ngủ thư giãn và
của anh đép Nguyễn à không Hình như ông
ng
98 Tôi sẽ gọi là
em
ngn đúng nhỉ Nhớ 98 gì
phải 99 à â Thế thế em đúng không Nhưng
mà tôi cảm thấy tôn trọng một khản nhất
định nên là tôi lúc đầu tôi Tôi nghĩ là
anh
đấy là về sau ông kia cứ nói được hai
câu rồi bị hạn chế
chế vậy ông Tùng Phạn kìa
bình thường Cứ thỉnh th bị hạn chế không
hiểu Ờ đấy Thì đại khái là bây giờ tôi
vẫn đang xem X nói bao gồm cả gia đình
của đ ngyễn máy nói thanh xuân đúng
không ạ Đấy cặp thấy là bình thường Thực
ra tôi không xem nhiều của De bến
thế không thần tượng
ai đến mức độ thế kết hợp việc làm Nếu
nế mà theo dõi Nếu mà để nó thân tượng
Tôi không phải thân tượng de hoàn toàn
tôi sẽ thân tượng anh J này anh Xân Bắc
này giáo sưng Xoay này giáo sư cô Trọng
Xoay V Xân Bắc hay đấm nhau ít nhất
trong cái chương trình đấy gì nh Ừ thầ
tượ ai
không nói đến diễn viên
chung là thưởng tượng vài
người Anh p pi nữa cũng có dvm mai rồi Ờ
ễn thì nhưng mà đương nhiên là học hỏi
được rất rất
nhiều cảm thấy rất là nề anh độ với cái
em em đ gọi anh thô cứ gọi Đé đi đấy đại
khái học hỏi rất nhiều và thấy được sự
trưởng thành của họ
kiểu từ Cứ cho là từ lần đầu tôi xem của
De đi đến bây giờ mọi người nếu mà xem
thì thấy là có thay đổi rất
lớn bao gồm cả về video à cách chỉnh sửa
làm video mọi thứ kiểu truyền đạt được
thông tin mọi thứ rất là hay rật bánh
cuốn mang tiếng là xem cái video này nó
rất là dài Nó hay tiếng 40 phút nên là
tôi nhưng mà đại khái tôi xem được hơn
một tiếng rồi thì tôi cứ mở lên lúc ăn
ngồi xem Thì đại khái
vừa mới nghe được xong đấy Tuổi thơ đã
hình thành tính cách như nào đươ nhiên
là cái này tất cả có rất nhiều cái bạn
sẽ kể đọc cái tiêu đề này có thể bạn sẽ
cảm thấy là nó là à Chào bạn Cường ạ s đ
chủ lực sau sau livestream này vào làm
ván l l nhá ông đợi rồi tí đấy
thì có vài người sẽ coi mấy cái này đều
hiển nhiên theo kiểu
mấy cái biết rồi những cái điều tôi đang
nói những cái điều mà ai cũng biết rồi
nhưng mà chúng ta vẫn phải nhắc lại cho
nhau nghe và cái này như thế kiểu làm
nào để bé được như
thế Ơ bị mất mic
đề
à Có gì âm thanh vấn đề bảo tôi nhá Đấy
thì
ờ đép được như thế em gái đép được như
thế các thứ thì cái Vlog kia rất là hay
bởi vì nó có cả bố mẹ
của của gia đình Nói chung cả cả gia
đình luôn nên là kiểu mấy ông sẽ thấy
được là kiểu người bố như nào người mẹ
như nào nên kiểu các con cái nó sẽ như
nào vân vân cảm thấy là
Tôi nghĩ là chắc chắn là mấy cái link
này mấy ông nên nghe
để nói thẳng luôn là tôi cũng thừa nhận
tôi có ai cũng bị bệnh về tâm lý cả bao
gồm cả
tôi xem nghe một cái này để mình biết
được
là mình không cô đơn mình không Nói
thẳng luôn là có thể là nhiều ông còn tự
Hà là mình không bị bệnh tâm lý gì cả
Không tôi nghĩa có thể ông bị một cái gì
đó là
mình chưa giác ngộ ra đấy Kiểu thế mình
nghe để mình Mình biết được và có khi
mình bị dính phải thì mình còn sửa còn
nếu mà không dính phải thì tuyệt vời quá
đấy C Thế ông chỉ biết được à mình may
mắn hơn rất nhiều người kia bị dính đấy
nhưng mà đại khái là tôi nghe xem một
vài cái Podcast cái này Thực ra đôi khi
liên quan đến sách đấy nhưng mà tôi còn
chưa đọc m quyển đấy mà người ta đã tóm
tắt Mọi thứ rất là hay thế rồi
sau này đi vô
học
Ừ để nói về cái video kia thôi
nhé tôi xem Đấy
xong nếu mà để mà suy nghĩ là kì ước mơ
K tôi sẽ ở trong cái gia đình kiểu như
thế và được đi s học như thế thì chắc cả
tôi không Ước như thế nên là chắc là tôi
cũng không h là ước cho con mình như thế
à Không phải tôi không thích kiểu như
thế Ui cái đấy Phả kiểu tôi thấy là nó
đối với tôi đối với tôi nó là một màu
hồng ấy không biết là ra cảnh họ như nào
vớii tôi đấy là một màu hồng màu rất
hồng luôn nhưng mà Ừ tôi cảm thấy ít
nhất là ơ giống như là trong de trong
video ấy từng nói là kiểu có khổ đau
thương đâu mới trân trọng đấy tôi thấy
trân trọng cuộc sống tôi ít nhất là thời
điểm hiện tại M dù nó không không B màu
hồng
thấy
là lý tưởng thì vẫn muốn con mình
à học tại đất nước mình được đào tạo
chính mình bởi vì nó sẽ có văn hóa mọi
thứ của mình đương nhiên là cũng muốn nó
mở mang đồ Hóc hơn nên là nếu mà C Má mà
muốn đi học thắc sĩ thì chắc là vấy có
thể sá n ng ngoài có thể thế không biết
được là có thể sắn ngoài được để học bác
sĩ hay không nhá n đang nói trước mắt
thì tôi lập tự tôn tôi mọi thứ tôi vẫn
muốn là mình
à và dạy được cái tụ tôn cho nó ấ mình
sẽ cần mọi thứ là kiểu học văn hóa nước
nhà mọi thứ của nước nhà đã ông ông hiểu
gì Tôi không chắc ai hiểu mà Đúng đấy
đấy với tôi làm tự tôn tôi như thế
hạn chế Sính Ngoại rất nhiều người kiểu
bị Sính ngoại quen ấy Kiểu mình mình là
còn nhiều lúc thì đương nhiên là mình
cảm thấy là mình cứ cho là Tuổi Thơ Mình
không được may mắn thành ra mình muốn
con mình về sao được may mắn được mọi
thứ tốt hơn đúng không Nhưng mà chính vì
như thế Tôi nghĩ tôi nghĩ là bọn nó sẽ
thiếu sự tự trải nó sẽ không chải không
quen chải cái khổ nên thành ra là kểu nó
sẽ nghĩ là cái điều kia thứ nhất là điều
hiện nhiên thứ hai nó sẽ bị Sính ngoại
quán sẽ nghĩ là mấy cái điều kiện X khi
nó về về đất nước ấ nó sẽ nghĩ là kì Nó
không cái đất nước mình lạc hậu th thế
Nó không văn minh như nước ngoài vân vân
Chẳng ạn thế sẽ So sánh thế tôi cảm thấy
nó một cái thứ không Hay đấy Đấy là đang
theo góc nhìn của tôi Tôi không biết
được nó đúng hay sai nhưng mà Tạm thời
Tôi nghĩ thế C cho là tự ăn đổi bản thân
đi không phải do nèo à không có tiền du
học đâu
học bạn qua chuỗi video có giớii điệu
Cảm ơn bạn Và chúc bạn sự khỏe Dạ xin
cảm ơn ạ
u học qua chuỗi video cơ sợ liệu là một
trong những cái video đầu tiên của mình
B tâm huyết nhất của mình luôn gọi tâm
huyết nhất bởi vì mình tự tin nhất về
cái Hiến thức của bên đấy và thể rất là
lâu rồi đấy vì kiểu hi vọng là kiểu bạn
và bạn hiện tại công việc mọi thứ ổn
định là nhiều và tận dụng được được cái
gì tận dụng đúng không ạ
Đấy biết đầu bạn ấy có gia đình nói thế
Có khi là thường các bạn có gia đình các
thứ thứ rồi
à Đã nói rồi nhỉ video này là bạn này
review mọi thứ kiểu Đúng chắc là quen đi
review thấy mọi thứ rất là hay vui và có
nhắc đến qua Quê của tôi nhá quản trị V
đi qua quản trị bạn đấy có đề cập cái
quả là bạn
đấy Bình thường là bạn đến các tỉnh khác
thì bạn ấy có thể gửi xe sạc rồi bạn sẽ
đi đâu đó để mà để mà kiểu câu thời gian
à hỏi câu thời gian là kiểu giết thời
gian một tí thế đ đợi sạc xong rồi Bạn
ấy về xe rư qua quản trị kiểu đến cả mấy
cái quán nước ở bên cạnh không có ra bạn
đấy rồi chơ 30 phút vậy đi à Thế Thành
ra tôi cảm thấy Ui tôi về quê đợ tới
không biết thế nào rồi tôi còn định à
còn định máu hơn à Về quê ở Quản trị như
thế xong tôi C định bắt đầu từ quản trị
về Hà Nội nữa bởi vì đấy tôi nhớ ấn T
hồi bé giờ tôi được đi tàu từ Hà Nội và
Đà Nẵng rồi trải nghiệm mọi thứ rất là
rất là tuyệt vời nên H là tôi ấn tượng
cả tàu cho dù tàu Hồi đấy còn không hiện
đại như bây giờ không dùng từ hiện đại
không đúng lắm thì bây giờ T không chắc
bây giờ hiện tại hơn mấy như gi Chắc
chắn là sạch sẽ hơn tôi nghĩ thế đấy đại
khái kìa tôi cân nhắc vãi chưởng Anh em
ở nào ở đây ở Quản trị mà hỗ trợ được CH
tôi thì tốt
xem Xin để lại link ở đây
Ờ Uầy nãy giờ chỉ dừng m mức tâm sự gần
hai tiếng luô trả lời câu hỏi sao được
Thôi cố trả lời nh Nhanh
nhá thì những thứ tôi tâm sự những thứ
tôi chia sẻ không đến chính tôi thì tôi
còn không nh nhớ hết được nghĩa là phải
chải dần thì mới nhớ hết được Tức là sao
nghĩa là k Khi mà mình đến cái giai đoạn
bay hay t
hả TH là may là tôi đến cái giai đoạn mà
thầy gọi
là đấy cũng ổn định được một tí tài
chính không nên tôi không quan tâm vì về
giá thực ra tôi từ trước này tôi đã cố
có quan điểm là không quan tâm về giá
nữa
là may mà giờ kiếm được công việc khiến
cho mình nhẹ đầu hơn được quả này không
quan tâm về cái đấy
lắm mà đ công ty tôi còn tái chợ tôi về
vé nghĩa là công ty nghĩa là như nào
công ty tôi bay và Đà Nẵng đi du lịch
nên tôi được miễn khoản bay rồi tôi C
xin đi tàu về mà chứ không phải là công
ty không tay trợ cái
rẻ luôn
Hiểu không Chứ không phải quan tâm việc
đi máy bay bay thì Tôi bay Tôi công ty
tôi cho bay từ Đà Nẵng về Hẳng Hà Nội
quán trị các thứ thế xong rồi bá bá tôi
ở còn bảo là ở quê còn chẳng có ai cả về
đấy không biết kể làm
gì cấn vãy
cho việc đi du lịch mà đự nhiên là tài
trợ cả vé Đương nhiên
rồi và công ty là công ty A Trang thêu
mạnh đệ tử thì ch rã ràng
là
nó nhắc đến công ty công nghệ ấy thì ông
mà thấy công ty đấy mà không phát triển
được ấy thì nó chỉ có chết thôi giống
như sắ bình Hồi trước nói ấ lợi nhuận
Nếu mà lợi nhuận tốt ấy thì phải x 10
lần lên so với tiền vốn nếu chứ nếu mà
số tiền Bỏ ra ấy chứ nếu mà công ty công
nghệ mà kiểu lẹt đẹt theo kiểu dạnh chỉ
lãi được kiể 20 30 ph hay 50 ph thôi ấ
công ty đấy công ty đấy Sắp sắp chết sắp
nẹp đấy Sắp
là nó là dùng công nghệ làm cốt lõi mà
máy tính các thứ thứ thiết bị thì nó có
thể chạy ầm ầm ầm 24 24 đúng Kiếm bao
được tiền lúc ấy Mình chỉ cần tiền nhân
sự về để quản lý được cái phần nào đó
thôi đúng không ạ Còn đâu để máy móc
chạy hết rõ ràng là lợi Nhận phải cao nó
khác với những cái kiểu công ty truyền
thống khác ph phát này dùng người kiểu
cứ tăng thêm người thì tăng thêm tiền
kiểu thế kiểu một người thì kiến nó được
20 trả nó 10 triệu mình lãi được 50 ph
gi gi sự thế con ty công nghệ không như
thế đúng không đấy Nên là nên cái việc
mà kiếm được của một công ty công nghệ
là điều bình thường tôi nói đấy ông mà
làm một công ty nào mà Ông thấy là nó
đang chỉ có lãi tầm ít ít ấ Chắc chắn là
công ty đang có vấn đề ông phải cân nhắc
nhi việc nghĩ phương án dựng phòng dần
đi Đúng rồi Tôi vẫn làm ở công ty
quá nhiều bài học tất cả chị là tôi có
thể chia sẻ mấy cái này mấy ông có thể
là nghe cho vui cũng được bởi vì là bây
giờ có thể mấy ông chưa trải hoặc là
trải quả xử rồi đấy Nên là mấy ông có
thể là không cảm thấy nó cần thiết lắm
nhưng tôi cảm tôi lại có tư duy thế này
đôi khi ông nghe mấy cái điều này ông cứ
có nghĩ đến nó là được rồi về sau khi mà
có nhắc lại hoặc là cuộc đời vả em mình
gái đúng không ạ hi vọng M không bị vả
nhiều cái thế nhưng mà chỉ lúc đấy ông
sẽ sẽ kiểu tô nghĩ nó rồi mà đúng không
bật số nhanh hơn đấy để mà để mà kiểu ra
được những cái quyết định đúng đắng đúng
không ạ Chứ đừng cố nhớ hết làm sao thể
nhớ được hết không thể học được hết
không thể làm được phải phải trải mới
biết được đúng không ạ hi vọng Mấy ông
không bị vả
à C bị vả nhiều hoặc là nếu bị vả rồi
thì hãy hãy bị vả nan nà giống tôi thì
mấy ông giú kinh nghiệm được từ từ việc
tôi chia sẻ chá Tôi chúc như thế không
chúc thầ có được gọi là chúc không nhỉ
Nếu mà tôi không thể chúc chục đời mấy
ông mồi Hồng được như cũng chụ cuộc đời
màu hồng người ta lại không phân biệt
đấy là màu hồng đâu người ta sẽ nghĩ đấy
là cuộc đời đơn điệu một màu ấy nó bị
chán ấy nhưng mà không thể chúc cuộc
sống vất vả nhiều màu được
để trúc đôi khi là rất khó nhở à đấy t
nốt lại để mà trả lời sang những câu hỏi
cũ Ok đã xong
ạ đấy sang câu
sống mồ Hùng thật đấy rất nhiều độ tuổi
luôn ấy nên
là nên là lúc đấy Tôi không biết khuyên
mấy ông lấy cái gì
luôn hôm nay có một người hỏi tôi trên
YouTube như này với người mới thì làm
sao để nắm được nhanh hệ thống flow chủ
đạo của dự án đó ạ thì đầu tiên thì tôi
có để link này để bạn ấy thể tham khảo
đại khái nó
lên nói thực ra không trả lời trực tiếp
câu này lại nói về là các bạn nghĩ sao
về Convention flow chuyên
nghiệp khi là cả công ty đấy Mọi thứ
chạy nhanh kiểu ăn liền hay là chặt chẽ
viết kiểu chuyên nghiệp cẩn thận đấy còn
nên tiếp tục công việc này không có rất
nhiều người trả lời trong này rất nhiều
cái câu hay cũng rất nhiều luồng suy
nghĩ có nhiều người thì quan điểm là gì
đây chỉ công việc kiểu làm kiếm n thêm
thu nhập kiếm được thêm tiền nên là quan
trọng nhất là đồng tiền bạn làm cái gì
Giả được tiền thì làm không quan tâm lắm
đấy Còn tôi thì có điểm khác rất nhiều
chắc là tôi chưa bị áp lực về động tiền
lắm còn đương nhên trong này có rất
nhiều người kiểu trả lời có tâm sự kiểu
trả th trải hơn nên là bạn đấy có thể
đam khảo thêm ở đây Tại sao lại đề cập
câu này câu này rõ rng cũng nhắc đến mỗi
hai từ kiểu lâu thôi mà có liên quan đâu
đúng không ạ N không Cái đấy để biết
được là thứ nhất là bạn lại có dùng từ
nắm được nhanh
nhanh hay không thì đấy là do bạn chứ
không ng thế chỉ là bạn được đường tắt
cả đường nào cũng phải chạy thôi đúng
không ạ
thì thì cái đường đúng ý thì sẽ là cái
đường mà trong bài kia có đề cập bạn
thấy đường nào hợp lý để làm
đấy còn và thường là nên học hỏi luôn
học hỏi từ những người đi trước Nếu mà
công ty bạn có le Đơ hay là chị giả
người vào trước bạn thì bạn nên kiểu
đấy nhất quan hệ đúng không ạ Đấy nhì là
đi Tiền à Không biết được như đại khá
bạn nên kiểu trao đổi các thứ trao đổi Ở
đây không phải là hỏi họ mọi thứ cũng
như là chưa chắc họ đã trả lời đúng cũng
như là họ chưa chắc trả lời bạn Vân Vân
như mà chị có trao đổi để biết thêm được
cái gì tốt V Đấy đúng không ạ không rồi
Hỏi là nhanh nhất
nhưng mà vừa nãy tôi cũng có Đề cập về
việc là là đặt tâm và câu hỏi nĩ là bạn
vẫn phải tìm hiểu đã sau đó thì mới C
mới hỏi đúng không ạ tránh việc là chưa
chưa tìm hiểu cái gì đã hỏi thì bạn sẽ
không biết hỏi cái gì cả và bạn sẽ hỏi C
những câu chung chung và câu chung chung
thì người ta sẽ một là không trả lời hai
người ta chỉ trả lời chung
chung đấy th tiếp theo đó là
bài kia
là công ty của bạn ấy hình như làm ao
xộc nghe thành ra bạn không cần quan tâm
về việc là maintain dự án hay là quản
bảo chình dự án nên là thành ra là kiểu
lương thì cao và bạn không quan công ty
bạn không quan trọng về cái việc là flow
nó lắm Cứ làm được việc là làm đấy chạy
được là được
thì cái bạn đang đặt câu hỏi này này tôi
cũng không biết được bạn bạn đề đang làm
ă à Làm kiểu làm thuê như thế hay là
product sản phẩm của chính công ty bạn
nếu mà sản phẩm của chính công ty bạn
thì chắc chắn là sẽ phải có rất nhiều
người đã kỳ cựu làm ở đây để bạn thể hỏi
còn nếu mà xộc thì đươ nhiên là thanh
nhân viên nhanh
vì dự án nhanh đến nhanh đi người cũng
thế nên là nên
là cái việc mà làm ở ao xộc thì chắc
chắn là bạn sẽ phải tự học khá là nhiều
nên là cá nhân tôi thì tôi không thể
khuyên là các bạn nó C nghỉ hết việc thì
nhả sang prod đu được không có nhiều
công ty product như thế nhưng mà bạn
cũng phải đấy thì bạn ý ý tôi nãy giờ
tôi muốn đ cập chung quy lại nó vẫn chỉ
là tôi vẽ tôi không vẽ được cho bạn con
đường nào cả đấy Tôi chỉ nói bạn là Ừ
cái bức tranh nó như thế bạn xem là bạn
tự trọng ra được là chính bạn đấy được
không ạ câu trả lời thế chắc là nó cứ bị
chung chung nhưng
mà nhưng mà nó không thể cụ thể được ý
đấy do tôi không nói việc là bạn hỏi C
chung chung đâu nhá Nhưng mà Đấy là do
tôi không hiểu được rõ bài toán đây nên
tôi phải trả lời như thế Ok không ạ rồi
nhá 2025 nên học nốt hay pp ạ tôi dạy pp
nà này tôi không thể
À tôi không thể khuyên mấy ông thì sao
Note được nhưng mà đúng Note p Note hay
pp thường ng Tôi so sánh và tôi cảm thấy
là nó đang ngang nhau đang ngang nhau
Tôi đang thấy thế tôi không thấy thằng
nào đang nhìn hẳn hơn thằng nào Ok không
ạ Rồi mình tìm kiếm công việc qua kênh
nào với anh số lượng thì này ha đang C
cá tránh ra cả hôm trước tôi có đề cập
vụ này một lần với sinh viên tôi ở trong
discord lúc mà anh em đ Chơi game nhưng
mà nhưng mà chưa đề cập Thăng trên đây
tôi xin phép nói
nhưng bạn phải xác định là có một l lớn
người học it theo phong trào Nói thẳng
luôn là có cả trường đại học dạy IT cũng
theo phong tr pho nốt nên thành ra chất
lượng đầu ra của họ cũng không cao đấy
Nên là bỏ qua được cái lượng đấy thì
tính ra là mình không hẳn là cạnh tranh
cao đâu mà mình cạnh tranh vừa phải thôi
Bởi vì cái ngành này như mấy ông thấy là
chỉ những tuyển những người giỏi tuyển
những người có kinh nghiệm không tuyển ở
interm
có nhiều có nhưng mà đương nhiên là cũng
kiểu gọi chọn lọc hơn nhưng mà Mấy ông
có thấy không bây giờ để mà nói lên len
ạn cứ nói lướt ba người 3 HR thì phải có
một HR làm IT làm về it thì rõ ràng là
là nhu cầu tuyển việc
của ngành công nghệ tin này tôi thấy
đang rất cao đấy chứ đúng không ạ Đấy
thì có phải đương nhiên là tuyển người
mọi mọi à trình độ nhé cả trình độ kiểu
trình độ xo có trình độ fer cũng
có nhưng mà họ bắt đầu không muốn đang
công khai cái việc tuyển vesser mấy nữa
bởi vì sao
vì nộp một cách quá tải và nộp một cách
kiểu nó na ná giống như cả như nào
nhỉ Tôi sẽ lấy ví dụ th tôi thường hay
lấy ví dụ sang bên chuyện tình cảm hẹn
hò một tí cho Chắc mấy ông dễ hình dung
đây mấy ông mới thấy các bạn nữ nào
kiểu trừ khi ở kiểu như nào đấy một
thiếu tốn hay là kiểu gì
đó cho mấy bạn bán hàng hay gì gì đó
thôi mấy bạn ấy mới đang công khai là
mấy bạn ấy đang tìm mối quan hệ hay gì
gì đó đúng không ạ Kể cả bạn đ có độ
thân hay không Tôi nghĩ là kể Dạ như này
mấy bạn phải tìm hiểu cực K
kỹ công ty đ đã cũng như là viết một cái
CV phù hợp với công ty này đã thì mức độ
tuyển vào các bạn mới cao còn các bạn đi
giải khính một cách tràn lan rồi Kiểu hi
vọng trúng ai đ trúng thì nó thấp lắm
kiểu dạng Trừ khi civ bạn quá đẹp đúng
không ạ mà không hiểu ý tôi không Tôi
thường ha So sánh cái việc tìm được công
việc của mấy ông không khác gì phải hẹn
hò cả thế là mấy ông không Mấy ông không
Tôi từng đánh giá CV của một vài Ông mấy
ông viết cho có xong rồi đi
gửi bừa đấy Xong rồi Thậm chí là người
20 rồi trúng được hai hai công ty phỏng
vấn ng không tìm hiểu về công ty đấy
trước khi phỏng vấn không chẩn có chuẩn
bị nhá như mà không tìm hiểu chỉ làng
chuẩn bị tốt với bản thân không tìm hiểu
gì về công ty cả Không biết công ty làm
product hay Cùng lắm thì biết công ty
đang tuyển là ngôn ngữ nào hết đấy thì
thì nó không ổn thôi đúng
trường đào tạo nó nhiều đang nói là theo
phong trào nhiều nên là mấy ông đừng có
đừng có ngại về vấn đề đấy cả nó nan á
Nó nan á giống như kiểu đấy Bây giờ có
nhiều bạn nữ độ thân đấy không có nghĩa
là vàng nhưng mà có tỉ lệ Nam hình như
cao nữ mà đúng không Cạnh tranh nó vẫn
cao mà Đúng không mấy ông nói thế thì
không phải mấy ông sẽ bỏ cuộc đúng không
Vẫn phân đấu thôi cạnh tranh với nhau
thôi tô thế nó quá bình thường cái gì mà
không Cạnh tranh m đáng lo đúng không
Công cái công ty mà không ai dắm chỉ vào
ấ công ty nào mà kiểu nó dễ nó dễ vào ấy
cảm thấy nó có khi nó cân cần đấy đúng
phần đầu để đạp được mình cảm thấy trân
trọng hơn
chung là đại khái thì tôi sẽ tôi từng
hứa mế mà tôi
sẽ học đi là à đi dậy lại rồi Vân Vân
sau đó máy làm lại bộ khung chương trình
dạy nhưng là cái này nó sẽ rất còn xa
Nói chung là khi là phải đến nói đời đến
đời con các bạn hơi cao nhưng mà chắc là
đến
đời Cứ cho là cháu của các bạn đi cháu ở
đây không phải
là con của con của bạn đâ cháu ở đây là
mấy cái đứa mà đã gọi các bạn là chú
ngay từ bây giờ
ấy con của
chị con của chị bạn ấy kiểu kiểu thế con
anh chị bạn ấy chả đến đời đấy tôi sẽ
lúc tôi sẽ ra được những cái chương
trình dậy vì tôi Tôi vẫn nhớ là có một
bạn gần đây bạn ấy cũng nhờ tôi dạy cho
cháu bạn đấy rồi mà sẽ TH Nghĩa là đến
lúc đấy Có khi tôi mới bắt đầu lên được
cái không chương trình mới cứ xa tầm tầm
đấy 10 năm
chuyên về ĐT nét nhưng mà học xin sác cơ
bản
mà rõ ràng trong bản thân nó tự trả lời
cho mạ đúng không em cứ theo sợ em ạ em
theo em
a đừng cái nào nó cũng sẽ ổn định khi mà
tâm lý em ổn định đấy cả chuyện lấy vợ
cũng thế
đấy Đừng có phân vân nữa dứt khoát chọn
một và cắm đầu vào Theo em kiểu như thế
thì em sẽ còn phân vân mãi tâm lý em
không ổn định nên cái nào nó thành không
ổn định thôi đấy nhá Ok chưa Uầy mà ngồi
chả câu hỏi tâm sự
hết hai tiếng rồi Ok tôi khản vọng rồi
mấy ông ạ xong mày tạm nghỉ ở đây thôi
đầu tiên là à đấy tôi hỏi mấy ông mấy
cái này
ông ông nào xem được cái đoạn này thì
cũng có thể inbox tôi trả lời h tôi
những cái mà tôi hỏi đấy
nhá chứ tôi hết hơi để mà ngồi nói lại
rồi Chào mấy ông
nha Cảm ơn ạ Cảm ơn đã lắng em Bye bye